You know Jason, have you ever ate at a mame? Because I've had a daddy. Never even met your mame. Oh, see, you did the joke too. I do like, you know what I really like doing with the at a mame, especially if I'm sitting across the table from my daughters. Yeah. Is that like to take one of those at a mame beans, like to fire like squeeze it and fire
你知道，杰森，你吃过毛豆吗？因为我吃过毛豆。甚至都没见过你吃毛豆。哦，你看，你也开了个玩笑。我确实喜欢，你知道我特别喜欢怎么吃毛豆吗，特别是当我坐在女儿对面的时候。对。就是把其中一颗毛豆，就像是把它捏一下，然后发射
one of those beans right at my daughters? Right. That's right. Yeah. Of course, you know, 16 year old gets pissed off at the 11 year old. She opens the per mouth real wide and goes, yeah, try, try, try, I'll catch you. And that's fun. And then mom smacks me and and then dinner falls apart. Hey, remind me to skip sushi next time. Yeah, you should or just wear a helmet. Welcome to Smart List. Smart. Smart. Smart.
把其中一颗豆子直接射向我的女儿？对。没错。对。当然，你懂的，16岁的女儿生11岁妹妹的气。她把嘴巴张得大大的说：“来，来，来，我接住。”这挺有意思的。然后我老婆拍了我一下，接着晚饭就进行不下去了。嘿，提醒我下次别吃寿司了。对，你确实该这样，或者干脆戴个头盔。欢迎来到SmartLess。Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Blast. What's the purple sex toy over your right shoulder? There? In the back. Keep going.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Blast. 你右肩后面那个紫色的性玩具是什么？那个？在后面。继续。
That's the purple thing. That's just one purple thing. Right here, even further back. Oh, this? Yeah. By the way, you know what that is? Should it be in? Roller back, roller back.
那个紫色的东西。那只是一个紫色的东西。就在这儿，再往后一点。哦，这个？对。顺便问一下，你知道那是什么吗？应该是卷轴，卷轴。
That's the inside of like a metal, but it's a record. It's like a sound thing. Oh. And you can also stick it up your ass. That's what we're getting. Okay, so but wait, I want to say something about Jason's food because I FaceTime with Jay last week. And you do eat a lot of stuff, it is kind of a joke,
那是某种金属内部的东西，但它是一张唱片。它就像是个声音装置。哦。而且你还可以把它塞进你屁股里。这就是我们要谈的。好吧，但是等等，我想说点关于杰森饮食的事，因为我上周跟杰伊视频通话了。你确实吃了很多乱七八糟的东西，这听起来像个笑话，
but it's not really because you do for every, you know, cookie that goes in, it's like 20,000 pounds and not some bolts and twigs and sticks going. Yeah, that's right. So, but I FaceTime do, it's like 20,000 pounds of nuts and bolts and twigs and sticks going. That's right. So, but I face time due and you answer it and you were on the treadmill, that's the other thing, you constantly
但又不太像，因为你每吃下一块饼干，就得吞下大概两万磅的螺丝、螺母、细枝和树枝。对，没错。所以，但是当我跟你视频时，大概有两万磅的螺丝、螺母、细枝和树枝下肚。对，没错。所以，当我跟你视频时，你接了，而你正在跑步机上，还有一件事，你一直在
are on the treadmill constantly. Well, again, this is not constant, it's just discipline, it's one hour a day. No, I know, but it's good. But, and then we talk, and then we have, I brought up the porn thing again because I can't believe you're the only male in the world That doesn't look a porn but that we already talked about that and then
跑步机上，一直在跑。嗯，再说一次，这不是一直，这只是自律，一天一个小时。不，我知道，但这很好。但是，然后我们聊了，然后我们又提到了看色情片的事，因为我简直不敢相信你是世界上唯一一个不看色情片的男性，但这个我们已经聊过了，然后
One of you looked at any porn today No, no, I don't need the eyebrows. Well, no, you don't need to like but I meant like what a weird question You know, you guys look at it daily or weekly or what's the frequency? No, like again, more eyebrows. This isn't a, what about, is it once a week? More, I don't know, like the frequency of it, but I'm just saying that general is the spirit. You say, you don't know, let's hear it. No, like male guys, I agree guy looks at point. Anyway, yeah, but the other thing was, I want to talk about the headband that you were wearing,
你们谁今天看过色情片吗？不，不，我不需要你挑眉毛。好吧，不，你不需要像……但我的意思是，这是个多么奇怪的问题。你知道的，你们是每天看、每周看，还是什么频率？不，就像刚才那样，别再挑眉毛了。这不是一个……那这个呢，是一周一次吗？更多，我不知道，比如它的频率，但我的意思是总体的精神状态。你说你不知道，说来听听。不，就像正常男人一样，我同意男人都会看色情片。不管怎样，对，但另一件事是，我想聊聊你戴的那根发带，
while you were running on the thing. Seems kind of horny. It was, no, I've never seen you in that I've seen you in that like other like hats and stuff But I've never seen you wear the headband while you're on the trust. I still have that dumb long hair And I don't want it sweating into my eyeballs That was astonishing. It was like lover boy like the 80s band or something But it made you think of Gay porn. Yeah. Yeah. No, I don't know. I just thought I'd never seen you in that. Jason, it was Jason never, Jason never
就是你在跑步机上跑步时戴的。感觉有点风骚。那是，不，我从来没见过你戴那个，我见过你戴其他帽子什么的，但从来没见过你在跑步机上戴发带。我还是留着那傻里傻气长头发。我可不想让汗水流进眼球里。那太惊人了。就像是“恋人合唱团”（Loverboy）那种80年代的乐队或者别的什么。但这让你想到了男同色情片。对。对。不，我不知道，我只是觉得从没见过你戴那个。杰森，这绝不可能……杰森绝
would look at gay porn because he's too worried. Oh, wow. You're my pants grouting. Yeah. Well, no. Wait, what were you saying? What's my workout? Yeah, what's your workout? Get up. So you know what? It's, it's fine. Well, my hair is quite short right now, but when, if it's even a little bit longer, I have, it's the worst. If I'm, so that I don't sweat and I would never wear it outside because I'm embarrassed, it's old school bandana rolled
不会看男同色情片，因为他太担心了。哦，哇。我的裤子都出褶了。好吧，不。等等，你刚才说什么？我的锻炼方式是什么？对，你的锻炼方式是什么？起来。所以你知道吗？这，这挺好的。好吧，我现在的头发挺短的，但如果，哪怕稍微长一点点，我就会……这简直是噩梦。如果我在……为了不流汗，而且我绝不会在外面戴这个，因为我觉得太尴尬了，它就是老式的卷起来的头巾
and then kind of up here and then my hair is kind of sticking by. That's exactly what Jason was wearing. It's the worst, but I could never wear it like everybody who lives kids, Alessandro, everybody looks at me like, dude, that is the worst. I look like such a solid. Because you don't want to get zits, is that what it is? Well, you just don't want the hair dripping down his face.
然后大概绑在这儿，接着我的头发就会从这儿支棱出来。杰森戴的就是那玩意儿。这太糟糕了，但我绝不会像其他人那样戴它——住在那里的孩子们，亚历桑德罗，每个人看着我都像是在说：“老兄，这太逊了。”我看起来就像个大白痴。因为你不想长痘痘，是这原因吗？好吧，你只是不想让头发滴水到脸颊上。
You don't want the sweat. You don't want the sweat, because then you get zits if you sweat on your face. Well, I'm 53. I'm pretty good on that, but it's more and just don't want to get the sweat in my face. You know what I mean? I sweat out of my face. You know, it'm pretty good on that, but it's more and just don't want to get the sweat in my face. You know what I- I don't sweat out of my face.
你不想流汗。你不想出汗，因为如果你满脸是汗，就会长痘痘。好吧，我都53岁了，我在这方面保养得还不错，但主要还是不想让汗水流到脸上面。你知道我的意思吗？我脸上会出汗。你知道，我……我在这方面保养得还不错，但主要还是不想让汗水流到脸上面。你知道我——我脸上不出汗。
You know, it's sweat period. You what? I don't sweat out of your face. I never sweat for my face. I don't know why, because it's fucking getting on my teeth shirt. Boy, I'm getting on that, teeth shirt so quick. I want to get to our guest,
你知道，就是汗流不止。你说什么？我不在你脸上出汗。我脸上从来不出汗。我不知道为什么，因为汗水他妈的流到了我的T恤上。天哪，它很快就浸湿了我的T恤。我想请出我们的嘉宾，
because I can hear him really feel, I feel badly for him that he's had to listen to the porn and he's had to listen to the sweat. I don't sweat out of my face. Um, I don't. I don't. And he doesn't deserve it. You know why? Because this is a guy.
因为我能听到他……我真的为他感到难过，他不得不听我们聊色情片，还得听我们聊出汗。我脸上不出汗。嗯，我不会。我不会。他不该承受这些。你知道为什么吗？因为这家伙……
I use, do you like the term actors actor? I do like that. He's the kind of actor in the way I look at it is. He's the kind of actor that all us actors look out to. Yeah. You're like, yeah, this is the guy knows it. He's in in nervous. Well, the second you say actors actor,
我用……你喜欢“演员的演员”（actor's actor）这个词吗？我挺喜欢的。他是那种类型的演员，从我的角度来看。他是那种让我们所有演员都仰慕的演员。对。你会觉得，没错，就是这家伙，他懂行。他是内行。好吧，你一说“演员的演员”，
you know, they're friendly. Yeah, and they're just like, they've just done so much stuff, and they've done the dramatic stuff, and they've done the comedy, and they're good at all of it. And you don't regret some, because you're like, they're so good at it,
你就知道，他们俩关系很好。对，他们只是演过太多作品了，演过正剧，也演过喜剧，而且每一种都演得很好。你不会觉得有什么遗憾，因为你会觉得，他们实在是太棒了，
that you're like, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, and this guy's got, he's got an Academy Award nomination. He's got, he's won two Golden Globes. He's won a Primetime Emmy. He's won a Primetime Emmy. He's won four SAG awards. He's been in every imaginal. We were talking about one of his movies last night at dinner after you left, Jason,
以至于你会觉得，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，这家伙拿过奥斯卡提名。他拿过两个金球奖。他拿过黄金时段艾美奖。他拿过黄金时段艾美奖。他拿过四座演员工会奖。他演过所有你能想象到的……我们昨晚在你离开后吃晚餐时还在讨论他的一部电影，杰森，
because one of his co-stars was there from that film from years ago. He's been in, he's single-handedly responsible for the death of the Merlot business. He's played John Adams. He played Howard Starter Boss. Oh, I love him. I love him.
因为他当年的一个联合主演就在现场。他几乎是一己之力造成了梅洛红酒产业的消亡。他演过约翰·亚当斯。他演过霍华德·斯特恩的老板。哦，我爱死他了。我爱死他了。
Guys, I love Paul's view. I love him. I love him. I do this right? Okay. Yes. Oh, Lord. Yes.
伙计们，我太爱保罗·吉亚玛提（Paul Giamatti）了。我爱他。我爱他。我这样对吗？好的。是的。天哪。是的。
Well done. I love you. Hello, I love you guys. I love you. I love you guys. I love you. Look at you. Fantastic. Look at me. I mean, talk about the background.
干得漂亮。我爱你。嗨，我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。看看你。太棒了。看看我。我的意思是，谈谈这个背景。
Can you see me? Yeah, I like. We can hear you. Jason and Paul Jason's very confused right now because of all the books behind you. Look at that wallpaper behind you. It looks so sexy. It's all to green screen. Green's fantastic.
你能看见我吗？对，我喜欢。我们能听到你说话。杰森和保罗，杰森现在非常困惑，因为你身后的那些书。看看你身后的那个壁纸。看起来太性感了。全都是绿幕。绿幕太棒了。
Wait a minute. That's a moth trap. I see that. That's all to green screen. It's fantastic. Wait a minute. That's a moth trap. I see that. That's a very effective. It works like a charm. So listen, he's got, he's got at least 6,000 books behind him. And you've read all of them all back. No, no, I have a lot of them. I haven't read, well, some of them. I've read some of them. Jason, name a book quick. Where the sidewalk is. So no pornography, no books. It's pretty dry. It's just sugar and salt for me.
等一下。那是个捕蛾器。我看到了。全都是绿幕。太棒了。等一下。那是个捕蛾器。我看到了。非常有效。效果好极了。所以听着，他身后至少有6000本书。而且你把它们全都读……没有，没有，我有很多书。我没读过……好吧，其中一部分。我读过一部分。杰森，快说出一本书的名字。人行道尽头。所以没有色情片，也没有书。这挺枯燥的。对我来说只有糖和盐。
Those are my, those are my vices. I want to know about the books. Why the book's Paul behind you? I have a kind of manic thing. I honest to God, I have a kind of collecting manoeuvred with, with books. I put all my manic behavior into, into books. I get that. And you know what? If you had asked me to
这些就是我的，我的恶习。我想知道关于书的事。保罗，你身后为什么有那么多书？我有一种强迫症。说实话，我在收集书这方面有一种狂热的举动。我把我所有的强迫行为都倾注在，倾注在书本上了。我懂那个。你知道吗？如果你让我
describe, say, what would Paul Jimani's background be? I probably would have said a bookshelf. Bremler books. I probably given a few guesses or or a bunch of different glasses frames. Or a selection of Warby
形容一下，比方说，保罗·吉亚玛提的背景会是什么样的？我大概会说是一个书架。满满的书。我大概会猜几次，或者是一堆不同款式的眼镜框。或者是一大堆沃比·帕克（Warby Parker）眼镜
Parker just all back there. Paul, do you have a favorite bookstore? In New York, I like going to this. Yeah, I'm assuming you're a new year. Yes, I am. I like going to the Strand bookstore. That's a classic bookstore. It holds up. It was a good one out in LA called Iliad Books. That's a great. I know that one. But we, I was just at the Strand two weeks going it. It's really holding up, isn't it? It is still there. It's still there. Yeah, it's still there, which is nice. Wait, now who was so, so what was the film that you were referencing last night that one of our dinner guests was in? Private parts with Mary McCormick.
全都摆在后面。保罗，你有什么最喜欢的书店吗？在纽约，我喜欢去这家。对，我假设你是个纽约客。是的，我是。我喜欢去斯特兰德书店（Strand Bookstore）。那是一家经典的书店。它经受住了时间的考验。洛杉矶也有一家很棒的叫伊利亚特书店（Iliad Books）。那是一家很棒的……我知道那家。但我们，我两周前刚去过斯特兰德书店。它真的经受住了考验，对吧？它还在那儿。它还在那儿。对，它还在那儿，这挺好的。等等，那么是谁……那么，昨晚我们晚餐时提到的其中一位嘉宾演的是哪部电影？玛丽·麦克科马克（Mary McCormack）出演的《私人零件》（Private Parts）。
Oh, yeah. Wow. That is a deep cut. And we were talking about kind of love that movie, Paul. You're so great. I was very, very happy. It's a good movie. It's a really Thomas directed that, right? Yeah. Have you worked with her? I have not. I would like to. love that movie Paul, you're so great. It's a good movie. It's a really Thomas directed that, right? Yeah, have you worked with her? I have not. I would like to. So, so let me ask you about private parts now that we're on it.
哦，对。哇。那可真是个冷门佳作。我们当时在聊，真是太喜欢那部电影了，保罗。你演得太棒了。我当时非常非常高兴。那是一部好电影。是贝蒂·托马斯（Betty Thomas）导演的吧？对。你和她合作过吗？我没有。我很想。真是太喜欢那部电影了，保罗，你演得太棒了。那是一部好电影。是贝蒂·托马斯导演的吧？对，你和她合作过吗？我没有。我很想。所以，所以关于《私人零件》，既然我们聊到这儿了，我问你个问题。
How did that movie come about? Like, were you a fan or did you listen to Howard before leading up to that at all? Like a little bit, you know, but not much. I wasn't any kind of big because I didn't, I didn't realize, for instance, that guy I was playing was a real guy until about halfway into my little 10 you're doing the movie, which was a couple of weeks. And they said to me, how'd you nail this guy so well? And I said, this is an actual guy.
那部电影是怎么找上你的？比如，你本身就是粉丝，或者在拍之前就听过霍华德（Howard）的节目吗？就听过一点，你知道的，但不多。我算不上什么大粉丝，因为我当时甚至没有意识到，比如说，我演的那个角色是个真人，直到我拍这部电影大约进行到一半的时候——这部电影我也就拍了几个星期。他们对我说：“你是怎么把这家伙拿捏得这么准的？”我说：“这居然是个真人啊？”
And they were like, yeah, I feel terrible now because I've made a manist guy like the biggest asshole on the planet. And that this is a real person's children are going to see this. His wife is going to see this. This is horrible. And it got me a little nervous. I thought this is terrible. But so. Did you meet him? No, at one time I had to do in promoting something a few years later. You know, they, but like I was always the guy they make me do the drive time radio. Shit, they'd be like, well, you do the promotion on the drive time radio guys. And I've been talking to that.
然后他们说：“是啊。”我当时觉得自己糟透了，因为我把这个偏执狂演成了地球上最大的混蛋。而这个真人的孩子会看到这部电影。他的妻子也会看到。这太可怕了。这让我有点紧张。我觉得这太糟糕了。但是……你见过他吗？没有，几年后我有一次在宣传什么东西的时候……你知道的，他们总是让我去做黄金时段电台。那种破事，他们会说：“你去黄金时段电台做宣传吧。”我跟那个人聊过。
I only a couple of years ago. But it was always me. They may do that. So because of private parts, so I was always talking to some fucking guys in Oakland or something. And one day they patched him through. They put him on with me. And it was just incredibly uncomfortable. But you started me as a fellow who's pretty diligent
那是几年以前的事了。但总是让我去。所以因为《私人零件》这部电影，我总是在跟奥克兰还是哪里的某些混蛋聊天。有一天，他们把他的电话接通了。他们把他和我的线连在了一起。那感觉简直令人尴尬至极。不过，我一直听说你是个对自己所演的角色和其他方面非常用功的人。你是，还是不是？这是一个可怕的错误。这得看情况。有时候是的。有时候看情况。但有时候我会做大量的研究，有时候又完全不做。
about researching your parts and whatnot. Are you, are you not? Aronius mistake. It depends. And sometimes I am. Sometimes it depends. But sometimes I do a lot of research and sometimes I just don't.
这是怎么回事，如果你扮演的是一个非虚构角色，你就会做研究，而如果是……这得看情况。就像我拍过一部拳击电影。我拍过一部拳击电影，而且我很感兴趣。对，《铁拳男人》（Cinderella Man）。对，太棒了。我还因此获得了奥斯卡提名。是的，我确实获得了。
And what is it, if you're playing a nonfiction character, you'll do the research and maybe if it's a side depends. Like I did a boxing picture. I did a boxing picture and I was interested. Yes, Cinderella man. Yeah, so good. I'm nominated for an Academy Award of which I was. I was.
谢谢。是的，谢谢。太棒了。我想了解如何给拳击手的双手缠绷带。没错。我想了解所有这些东西。我学到了所有这些老派的技巧。他们会拿一个大大的冰冷银元
Thank you. Yes, thank you. So good. And I wanted to learn about how to rap guys hands. Right. And I wanted to learn all that stuff. And I learned all these old school tricks. They would hold a big cold silver dollar
按在拳击手的淤青上。这很有趣。我学到了各种各样的技巧。因为你本可以教他们，因为你很擅长在回合间隙给拳击手缠绷带。是的。是的。
against the guys' bruise. Well, it was fun. I learned all that kind of stuff. Because you could have taught them because you're pretty good at wrapping guys' hands while I rounds up. Yes. Yes.
是的。我待会儿向你展示。我待会儿向你展示。等等。你说的银元是什么意思？你在说什么？就像是消肿铁块（n-swell），对吧？拳击手会弄一个消肿铁块，意思是，
Yes. I'll show you later. I'll show you later. Wait. What do you mean, the silver dollar? What are you talking about? It's like an N-swell, right? Guys would get an N-swell, meaning like a,
这就是他们用来在眼眶红肿时推平眼皮的真实工具。那是一个带有小环的金属方块。对，没错。在老派作风里，因为我拍的那部电影背景设定在30年代，他们当时还没有那种东西。他们就只有一个冰凉的银元，把它按在拳击手的脸上。哦，只是为了消肿？对，没错。
it's like, that's like the real thing that they use to smear out a swollen eye or something. It's like a metal square that's got like a little ring. Yeah, that's right. And in the old school, because that movie I did set in the 30s, they didn't have those things. They would just have a freezing cold silver dollar and they put it, they pushed it against the guy's face. Oh, just to take the swelling down. Yeah, correct.
威尔，你有什么……你有什么消肿的好办法吗？这是，什么叫消肿？好吧，一切都好。我想那就是它的名字。不过，保罗，但是，但是，但是，关于我刚才的观点——你可能受过非常非常好的教育。我猜你去了……你是个耶鲁人吗，耶鲁毕业的？我去了耶鲁，我上了耶鲁戏剧学院。太惊人了。
Will, you got anything for, you got anything for N's well? It's, what is N's well? Well, all's well. I think that's what it's called. All's well, that N's well though. But, but, but, but Paul, but then yeah, what about my idea that you may be very, very well trained? I'm assuming you went to, are you a, you a jewelry art guy, a Yale guy? I went to Yale, I went to the Yale School of Drama. That's amazing.
话说，我们的朋友劳拉·琳妮（Laura Linney）是不是也在那儿？嗯，我记得她去的是朱莉亚学院（Juilliard）。她也是耶鲁的吗？天哪，我应该知道这个的。不，她是。你记得，对。对。嘿，杰森，你还记得你和她一起演过《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）吗？嗯，和她。对。没错。你演了那部电视剧。
Now, wasn't our friend Laura Lini over there? Well, she went to the jewelry art, I believe. Was she Yale as well? Maybe God, I should know that. No, she was. You remember, yeah. Yeah. Hey, Jason, you remember you were in Ozark with her? Uh with her. Yeah. That's right. You were in the television.
你还记得吗？他完全失忆了。对。我只能记起一个小时前的事。不，她大概是最顶尖的演员。所以，保罗。所以你去了……你提到你去了耶鲁，你是纽黑文本地人。你其实就在那儿长大，对吧？可不是嘛。你爸爸是……你爸爸是那里的教授，最后还成了耶鲁大学的校长，天哪。等等，你妈妈？你妈妈也在耶鲁教书吗？不，她在纽黑文的一所私立学校教书。对。所以你妈妈是个老师。所以他的父母都在耶鲁教过书。你应该纹一个耶鲁的纹章。我应该，我应该纹一个巨大的……我没有。我应该在屁股上纹一只斗牛犬。
Do you remember that? I've never been. How was that? Did you enjoy that with her? He's completely blanked it. Yeah. I only can remember just an hour ago. No, she's about the best average. So Paul. So you went to you mentioned so you went to yell you were you're you're from New Haven. You actually weren't there, right? No way. And your dad was, your dad was a professor there, ended up, ended up being, being the president of Yale and, oh my God. Wait, your mom? Did your mom teach at Yale too? No, she taught it at a private school in New Haven. Right. So your mom was a teacher. So both of his parents ran into Yale tattoos. You should have a Yale tattoo. I should, I should have a big, I don't. I should have a bulldog on my ass.
或者在小耳垂上纹一只大苍蝇。我真该在屁股上纹一只斗牛犬。我也是。对。但是等等，话说回来，在进耶鲁之前，你不能只是……这可不是靠你爸妈说一句“来吧，我搞定你了”就能进去的。
Or a big fly right on the small earball. I should always have a bulldog on my ass. Same. Yes. But wait a minute, what about, go back though before, in order to get into Yale, you couldn't just, it wasn't like your mom and dad were like, come on, I got you.
就像你读高中时，成绩肯定非常优异，对吧？我考得挺好的，对。我学术成绩挺不错的，对。你在纽黑文读的高中吗？没有，我读的是一所高中。我读的是一所预科学校。我读的是寄宿学校，但我没有住校。所以我走读……去上学。威尔，你读过寄宿学校，对吧？
Like you had a like high school, you probably excelled, right? I did pretty good, yeah. I was pretty good academically, yeah. Did you go to high school in New Haven? No, I went to a high school. I went to a prep school. I went to a boarding school, but I didn't board there. So I went, you know, to school. Will, you went to a boarding school, didn't you?
对，我在加拿大的寄宿学校读的，我们当时叫走读生，因为那里全是男生，走读生被称为“走读男孩”。对。肖恩，这有什么好笑的吗？我的意思是，这一整集节目真的要在克里斯蒂的历史月里引发一封投诉信了。加拿大的寄宿学校真的像英国寄宿学校那样可怕吗？
Yeah, I did up in Canada and then the day students, we call them, because there's all boys with they were called day boys. Yeah, day Sean anything? I mean, this whole episode is really gonna get a letter well My history month for Christy Is a Canadian boarding school is it is like horrendous as the boarding schools are seem to be an English? Well, no, but back then did I came you there? Did they like give you a good
嗯，不，但当时……我去了加拿大，他们会给你来个痛快的……痛快的一顿鞭笞吗？如果你，你知道的……他们甚至懒得去拿藤条，直接上手。我可没挨过容易的。对，那是在屁股上狠狠抽一下。不，对，我是认真的。
sound? Good sound frashing if you, you know, didn't even bother grabbing the can they just went with the hand. I'm not getting easy. Yeah, it's it's mapped in the back hit. No, yeah, I was serious.
你以前真的挨过打吗？对，对，对，我后脑勺挨了好几下，这算是个天主教学校吗？是耶稣会学校吗？这是一所老派学校。它是一所……我读的那所学校非常老派，
You used to get hit really. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got hit in the back of the head a bunch and was this like a Catholic school? Is it like Jesuit? It's an old school. It's a, it's a, I went to this school that's like a very old school
有点像当时那种英式寄宿学校。它现在变成男女合校了，完全不一样了，一切都变了。所以我……但在当时，它非常像一所老派英式全男孩寄宿学校。对，我们的兄弟学校是苏格兰的一所学校，叫戈登斯顿（Gordonston），你知道的，许多王室成员都在那里上过学，诸如此类。所以我们学校也有一些那种背景的人转学过来。当时西班牙王子费利佩——他现在是西班牙国王——就曾在我的学校上过学。对。
sort of British style boarding school at the time It's now co-ed in is very different is all change and so I'm but at the time it was very much a old English style all boys boarding school Yeah, and our our sort of brother school was this school in Scotland called Gordonston where you know You know a lot of the real family family went and et cetera, et cetera. So we had some members of those types of people came over to and went to my school as well. So the then Prince of Spain, Philippe, he's now the king of Spain was, what's my school? Yeah.
所以你从小也吃了不少苦，是吗，威尔？嗯，这跟那没关系。我当时就像是个一直挨饿的底层穷光蛋。这太疯狂了。你爸爸……人们会骚扰西班牙王子吗？你认识西班牙王子吗？对，我认识。
So you struggled a bunch growing up, did you will? Well, I had nothing to do with that. I was like, I was low man starving all the time. That's crazy. Could you have a dad? Did people harass the Prince of Spain? Did you know the Prince of Spain? Yeah, I did.
天哪，这话听起来太荒谬了，但他和我曾在一个滑雪队里。这简直太疯狂了。我也曾被大巴送到洛杉矶市中心的一所学校上学。对，好吧。对，我也曾步行去洛杉矶市中心的学校上学。对，好吧。对，我步行去上学时连饭都没得吃。对，没东西吃，没鞋穿，对吧，肖恩？
Boy, this is a terrible sentence, but he and I were on the same ski team. So that is crazy. And I got bust. I got bust to a school in downtown Los Angeles too. Yeah, okay. Yeah, and I had a walk a school in downtown Los Angeles too. Yeah, okay. Yeah, and I had a walk to school with no food. Yeah, no food, no shoes, right, Sean?
两头都要走，还没鞋穿。不管怎样，我们言归正传。所以我们考上了耶鲁，然后，当时你爸爸……你爸爸一开始是教授，后来成了耶鲁大学校长。所以，我觉得这确实有帮助，因为我知道其他人的父母可能也是大学教授。
Both ways, no shoes. But anyway, we're back. So we could bet to Yale and, and then, when your dad was, your dad was a professor in the beginning president of Yale. So that, I think it does help, because I know other people, probably, parents are professors at colleges.
对，但这只能帮你到这一步。你高中时成绩肯定非常好。你高中时相当不错。我当时是个聪明的孩子。那可不是一所普通的学校。我敢说表现相当不错。你的论文和那些东西。我想大概都很不错吧。
Yeah, but it only takes you so far. You must have done very well in high school. You were pretty good at high school. I was a bright kid. That was not a school. I bet was pretty good. And your essays and all that. I think probably they must have been.
我不记得我当时写了些什么论文了。我不记得它们是关于什么的了。你的课外活动有哪些？肯定很讨人喜欢。我的课外活动，这很有意思。我为校报工作，我画漫画。真的吗？哇。真的吗？哇。
I don't remember what my essays entailed. I don't remember what they were about. What were the extracurriculars? They must have been pleasing. My ex-cork, that's interesting. I worked on the school newspaper, I drew cartoons. Really? Wow. Really? Wow.
是的。我还做过什么？我在那里参加了一些戏剧活动。后来在快毕业的时候，我演了一些戏剧。嗯，你父母更希望或更兴奋于看到你成为一名学者，还是他们不介意你成为一名演员？
Yes. And what else did I do? I did some theater there. And I worked in the kind of ladder end of it. I did some theater. Well, you're parents more interested or excited about you becoming an academic, or were they okay with you becoming an actor?
我觉得他们对于我成为演员这件事还算能接受。我觉得他们……因为我家族里上溯的好几代人全都是老师。就像是……这太荒谬了。每个人他妈的都是老师。所以我觉得大家的假设是，他们三个孩子里总得有一个当老师的，我哥哥坚决不干。所以他们觉得这家伙会去当老师的。
I think they were okay with me becoming an actor. I think they, I think the extra, because everybody in my family going back was teachers. Like, right. It was ridiculous. Everybody is a fucking teacher. So I think the idea, the assumption was one of their three children was going to be a teacher, and my brother insisted and do it. So I think they thought this guy will do it.
然后我偏偏没去。你能想象保罗在亚历山大·佩恩（Alexander Payne）的电影里饰演一个纽约客漫画家吗？哦，对。我虽然还不知道具体的故事是什么，但我正在琢磨。我要打个电话。不过现在等等，我在这里可能会让自己出丑，
And then I just didn't. I could see, could you see Paul in a Alexander Payne film playing a New Yorker cartoonist? Oh, yeah. And I don't know what the story is yet, but I'm working on it. I'm gonna call. Now, but now wait, I might embarrass myself here,
但难道……你没有演过《幽灵世界》（Ghost World）吗？还是《漫画家克朗布》（Crumb）那部电影？我记混了。我演过一部电影叫《美国辉煌》（American Splendor），讲的是一个叫哈维·佩卡（Harvey Pekar）的家伙，而克朗布为他的作品画了插图，因为他自己不会画画。他不会画，是的，是的，不用谢。所以你猜得很近，威尔。
but didn't, where did you not do Crumb? The, the, the, the, the Crumb movie? My confusion. I did a movie called American Splendor about a guy, this guy Harvey Pekar and crumb did the drawings for his, because he couldn't draw. He couldn't, yes sir, yes sir, you're welcome. So you're close, well.
我非常接近。你在拍那部电影时，能用到一些你作为漫画家的才能吗？并没有。他自己不会画。所以我没办法画。哦，对。因为那是为他……
I'm very close. Were you able to use some of your talents as a cartoonist while while doing that film? Nope. He couldn't draw. So I couldn't. Oh right. Because who for him?
是的。不，我没能做那些事。我本来希望……我以前想当个漫画家，或者说动画师，那是我曾想做的事，但也就是想想而已。你在拍那部电影的时候，你知道那个家伙是真人吗？我知道。对。他大概知道吧。好吧。
Yes. No, I didn't get to do any of that. I wish I had wanted to be a cartoonist like an animator was what I kind of wanted to do, but that's that. Did you know that guy was real when you were doing that movie? I did. Yeah, he probably did. Okay.
我知道。我知道。我知道。是的。我当时……是的。不，我见到了真人本身。所以毫无疑问。那是真的。而且他很有涂鸦天赋。
I did. I did. I did. Yes. I was, yeah. No, I was I was confronted with the actual man. So there was no questioning. It was real. And he was very doodle.
你到现在还会涂鸦吗？对，没以前那么多了。我希望我能多画点。我画得没有以前那么多了。我想当我决定成为一名演员时，我就停止画画了。那只是我人生中一个不同的阶段，然后我就不画了。我想当我决定成为一名演员时，我就停止画画了，那只是我人生中一个不同的阶段，然后我就不画了。我偶尔还是会随便画画。
Do you doodle still to this day? Yeah, not as much. I wish I did. I don't draw as much as I used to. I think when I decide to be an actor, I stop drawing. And it was just a kind of different part of my life. And I stopped drawing. I think when I decided to be an actor, I stopped drawing and it was just a kind of different part of my life and I stopped drawing. I still do sometimes with nothing.
你最常涂鸦的是什么？我觉得每个人都有一样自己特别擅长画的东西。嗯，我画很多面孔，大多是那种生气的、留着胡子的老头。你家里有杰森的肖像画吗？对，就是那样的。
Yeah, what does your go to doodle? I think everybody's got one thing that they do know how to draw well. Yeah, well, I do a lot of faces mostly and it's kind of angry old men, moustache-y old men. You have portraits of Jason and your house? Yeah, that's exactly.
我11岁的女儿画画非常非常厉害。我前几天看她的作品时，
My, my 11 year old, a daughter is very, very good at drawing. And I was looking at some of her work the other day. And I said to her, I said, honey, you know, I notice a lot of the faces that you draw. There's a lot of tears coming out of the eyes. Is everything okay? She goes, yeah, dad. And I go, no, no, I mean, I just, you know,
我对她说：“宝贝，我注意到你画的很多面孔上，眼睛里都有很多眼泪。一切都还好吗？”她说：“挺好的，爸爸。”我说：“不，不，我的意思是，你知道的，
I'm trying to be good dad here. And I'm just saying that that's a flair for me. And I just want to make sure I check in with you. She's like, no, it's just really fun to draw. That is, you think that she was show so shocked that you noticed anybody other than yourself? That I knew my way to serve out of your own that didn't have to do with show business.
我只是在努力做一个好爸爸。我只是想说这对我来说有点敏感，我只想确保你一切都好。”她说：“不，这画起来真的很有趣。”你觉得她会这么震惊，因为你竟然注意到了除了你自己之外的其他人？我竟然能走出自己的世界，去关注一个和娱乐圈无关的人。
Something that wasn't stuck to the front of the television that I noticed. Yeah. She was the Dodgers. Yeah. Dodgers are gone. Do you still get a chance to do theater? Do you like doing it? Do you prefer like now that you are on this trajectory of 800 movies and TV shows?
注意到一些不贴在电视机前面的东西。对。她喜欢道奇队。对。道奇队已经出局了。你现在还有机会演戏剧吗？你喜欢演戏吗？既然你现在正处于拥有800部电影和电视剧的这种演艺生涯轨迹中，你会不会觉得：
You're like, I haven't done a play in a while. I do, I do like it. I do prefer it. You're doing a play right now. Yeah, show them like for you to take over form. You play in a while. I do, I do like it. I do prefer it. You're doing a play right now. Yeah. Showing like for you to take over form. You should have a thing. You want to step in.
“我已经很久没演过话剧了”？我确实，我确实喜欢。我更倾向于演话剧。你现在正在演一部话剧。对。就像是让你去接替……你已经很久没演过话剧了。我确实，我确实喜欢。我更倾向于演话剧。你现在正在演一部话剧。对。就像是让你去接替……你该有个东西。你想介入。
He's very tired. Yeah. You know, Paul actually was quite famously in a play with a very good friend of ours and a friend of the podcast, Billy Crude up in our case years ago. Oh, no way. What was it? Yeah. I did a couple of plays with Billy. I did a three case years ago. Oh, no way. What was it? Yeah. I did a couple of plays with Billy.
他太累了。对。你知道的，保罗其实非常著名地和我们的一位好朋友、也是本节目的朋友比利·克鲁德普（Billy Crudup）一起演过一部话剧，就在几年前。哦，真的吗？什么剧？对，我和比利合作过几部话剧。几年前我演过一部……哦，真的吗？什么剧？对，我和比利合作过几部话剧。
I did a three plays with Billy. Oh, wow. Billy just took $15 off me this weekend because his Yankees took two out of three from my Dodgers. Oh, you're gambling with Billy. But I only sent him $14. I kept the dollar back for the damage that Aaron Judge did to our bullpen fence. Did you see any of that footage? for the damage that Aaron Judge did to our bullpen fence.
我和比利演过三部话剧。哦，哇。比利这个周末从我这儿赢走了15美元，因为他的扬基队从我的道奇队手里赢下了三场比赛中的两场。哦，你在和比利赌博。但我只转给他14美元。我扣下了一美元，当作是亚伦·法官（Aaron Judge）对我们牛棚围墙造成破坏的赔偿。你看到那些录像了吗？当作是亚伦·法官对我们牛棚围墙造成破坏的赔偿。
Did you see any of that footage? He ran right through the wall, taking a scoring flyball away from us. It was a very, he had a, Aaron Judge had a very exciting weekend to hear in Los Angeles. Obviously this podcast is airing later than that, but Paul, I don't know if you're a big baseball fan,
你看到那些录像了吗？他直接撞穿了墙，从我们手里抢走了一记眼看要得分的飞球。这是一场……亚伦·法官在洛杉矶度过了一个非常刺激的周末。显然这期播客播出时已经是之后的事了，但保罗，我不知道你是不是个狂热的棒球迷，
I know that baseball runs in the family. It does. I'm not a huge baseball fan, but I occasionally follow it. Things like this. Tell Sean, well, tell Sean, because I don't know, Sean, you know, Paul's involvement with baseball, which is quite, you know, good.
我知道棒球在你的家族里很有渊源。确实如此。我不是个狂热的棒球迷，但我偶尔会关注。比如这种比赛。告诉肖恩，好吧，告诉肖恩，因为我不太清楚……肖恩，你了解保罗跟棒球的渊源吗？那可是相当……厉害的。
I don't know what's saying. And we can cut it too if you don't want to talk about it. No, no, no, no, no. After being in academia, my father ended up in professional baseball, and he ran the national baseball baseball. That's a commissioner major league baseball for leagues. That's like God of baseball. Basically, well, yeah, kind of. That's crazy.
我不知道该怎么说。如果你不想聊的话，我们也可以剪掉。不，不，不，不，不。结束学术生涯后，我父亲最终进入了职业棒球界，他担任了国家联盟……他是美国职棒大联盟（MLB）的总裁。那可是棒球界的上帝啊。基本上，嗯，算是吧。这太疯狂了。
It is crazy. And so he didn't, he didn't, he didn't, either one of those things for very long. But you, were you, did you go to a lot of games in that time where you, was it because it was kind of the family business that you were playing with? It was a big, big, big league business. It was a big league business.
这太疯狂了。所以他……他并没有在任何一个职位上干太久。但是你……你当时经常去看比赛吗？是因为这有点像是家族生意，所以你才……这可是大联盟级别的生意。这可是大联盟生意。
It was a big league business. It was a big league business. It was a big league business. It was a big league business. It was a big league business. It was a big league business. It was a big league business. It is crazy. And so he didn't, he didn't, he didn't, he didn't either one of those things for very long. But do you, were you, did you go to a lot of games in that time? Was it, because it was kind of the family business in a way? Yeah, I mean, I did. I went to some playoff games.
这可是大联盟生意。这可是大联盟生意。这可是大联盟生意。这可真是大联盟生意。这可是大联盟生意。这可是大联盟生意。这可真是大联盟生意。这太疯狂了。所以他并没有……他并没有在任何一个职位上干太久。但你……你当时经常去看比赛吗？是因为这在某种程度上算家族生意吗？对，我的确去过。我看过一些季后赛。
Now I'm a senior member of what once I went to. I wish I did. I wish I was paying more attention. I wasn't paying that much attention. But I did go to some, yeah. And, but, but not enough. I wish I'd gone a bit. That's why I asked you about extra curricular in high school like You know like like I was on the swimming team. I was on the swimming team. Oh, okay, that's about as well
现在回想起来，我真希望自己当时能多看点。我真希望自己当时能多上点心。我当时没怎么专心看。但我确实去看过一些，对。但是……还不够。我真希望自己当时能多去看看。这就是为什么我刚才问你高中的课外活动时……你知道的，比如我是游泳队的。我是游泳队的。哦，好吧，那也挺……
Interesting It's like to picture you swimming in high school is kind of interesting. It is interesting You know, I had hair I had hair. I went a little speedo So you did have hair. I had hair. I went a little speedo. So you did have hair. I did have hair. I actually had hair. But for swimming, you know, you would shave. You would actually shave your head.
有意思。想象你高中时在游泳的样子，这挺有意思的。确实挺有意思。你知道的，我有头发。我有头发。我穿过那种小三角泳裤。所以你确实有头发。我有头发。我穿过那种小三角泳裤。所以你确实有头发。我确实有头发。我其实是有头发的。不过为了游泳，你知道的，你得把头发剃光。你甚至会把整个身体的毛发都剃掉。
Of course. Yeah, they would pull that stuff. You would probably shave your old body. You would shave your whole body. Right? You would shave your whole body. Yes. Did you, Paul, you just said, I wasn't paying attention.
当然。对，他们会……你大概会把全身的毛都剃光。你真的会把全身的毛都剃光。对吧？你连全身的毛都会剃掉。是的。保罗，你刚才说：“我当时没专心。”
And I was actually thinking about this concept recently, about this idea of, as we get older, and I've been doing a lot more reflecting lately, about this idea of this stuff, I feel like, now I'm much more aware or cognizant, and I want to absorb everything much more now than I did when I was a younger man. All these things that we took for granted,
我最近其实也在思考这个概念，关于随着我们年龄渐长，我最近开始进行更多的反思，关于这种感觉——我觉得现在我有了更多的觉察和认知，我比年轻时更渴望去吸收一切事物。所有这些我们曾经视为理所当然的事情，
these experiences that we would have. Right? Have you guys had any of that recently? Well, but even just saying what I was saying to you, I regret that, I mean, I was in college and I was kind of checked out and I was sort of like, eh, not dealing with my dad and stuff like that. And I very much regret it now because he passed away very shortly after doing all of that.
我们经历过的这些体验。对吧？你们最近也有这种感觉吗？嗯，但就像我刚才对你说的，我感到后悔的是，我在大学时整个人处于一种游离状态，有点像“得过且过”，并没有好好跟我父亲相处之类的事情。现在回想起来，我对此感到非常后悔。
So I definitely regret that. And very much regret it now because he passed away very shortly after doing all of that. So I definitely regret that. And very much so. But I very much feel the same way that I need to be taking everything in way more than I did. And I wonder if my kid, my kid will remember, shed or regret shit the same way I did. But hopefully not. How old is your kid? How's your kid?
因为他在做完那些事不久后就去世了。所以我绝对对此感到后悔。而且是非常后悔。但我确实有同感，我觉得我需要把一切都吸收进来，比我当年做的要多得多。我在想，我的孩子，我的孩子以后会不会也像我一样对某些事感到遗憾或懊恼？但愿不会吧。你孩子多大了？你孩子怎么样了？
He's 22. He just graduated from college. Oh, wow. He's the age. I was when my father died I want to bring the whole show down by But he's the age my father was He's the age my father when my father died. So it's interesting to me to to think yeah, I remember I remember I worked with With Marcus with your brother on a very very shitty football movie No, I remember I remember I worked with with Marcus with your brother on a very very shitty football movie No, I remember movie very well. I
他22岁了。他刚从大学毕业。哦，哇。他正是我父亲去世时的年龄。我本不想用这个把整个节目的气氛弄得太低沉……但他正是我父亲去世时的年龄。所以对我来说，去思考这些挺有意思的，我记得……我记得我和你弟弟马库斯（Marcus）合作过一部非常非常烂的橄榄球电影。不，我记得……我记得我和你弟弟马库斯合作过一部非常非常烂的橄榄球电影。不，我记得那部电影非常清楚。我
Remember yeah, I remember just dorking out with him about about your dad and just like I've taken his brain about it He's a huge baseball fan. He's like a fanatic. Yeah, he said you good to it. I really like my time He is a good dude. That was I loved that movie. It was called necessary roughness. This football. He's back in the day was Scott back. No, he has been bad. The Ireland. Who else was in that? It was a lot of pro. Alizondo. I think that's it. Yeah. Jay, did you, Jay, did you take the moment during necessary roughness and really absorb it? Oh, I sure did absorb it. Wait, we're talking about two different things now. Well, we shot in Dallas, Texas. There was a lot of off time. They've got some nice ballet
记得……对，我记得当时还跟他大谈特谈关于你父亲的事，向他打听这方面的信息。他是个超级棒球迷。他是个狂热粉丝。对，他说你人很好。我真的很享受那段时光。他是个好人。那是……我太喜欢那部电影了。它叫《追梦赤子心》（Necessary roughness）。这部橄榄球……那是当年跟斯科特·巴库拉（Scott Bakula）一起演的。不，里面有海克特·埃里佐多（Hecter Elizondo）。还有谁演了？有很多职业球员。埃里佐多也在。我想就是这样。杰伊，杰伊，你在拍《追梦赤子心》时有没有花时间真正去体会一下？哦，我当然体会了。等等，我们现在是在聊两码事。好吧，我们在德克萨斯州达拉斯拍的。有很多空闲时间。达拉斯有一些非常棒的芭蕾舞剧
and Dallas. Absolutely. We'll be right back. Smartless is supported by Mint Mobile. Signing your life away to a big wireless provider is kind of like being trapped on a roller coaster. From hell, hell, hell. Sure, it looked fun at first. They probably threw in a free phone. But now you can't get off month after month of insane bills and unexpected thrills,
和……我们马上回来。SmartLess由Mint Mobile赞助支持。把你的生活绑定到一个大型无线通信运营商，感觉就像是被困在了一个从地狱来的过山车上。从地狱来的，地狱来的，地狱来的。当然，一开始看起来挺好玩的。他们可能还送了一部免费手机。但现在你根本摆脱不了接踵而至的疯狂账单和意想不到的“刺激”，
like overages and surprise fees. If that sounds like your current big wireless plan, it's time to get off the ride with Mint Mobile. For a limited time wireless plans from Mint Mobile are just $15. All plans come with unlimited talk and text plus high speed data delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number along with all your existing contacts. Ditch big wireless with Mint Mobile's limited time deal
比如超额费用和各种隐形收费。如果这听起来像你目前使用的大型无线套餐，是时候通过Mint Mobile从这个深渊中解脱出来了。限时优惠，Mint Mobile的无线套餐只需15美元。所有套餐都包含无限通话和短信，以及依托全美最大5G网络的高速数据。你可以用自己的手机搭配任何Mint Mobile套餐，并保留你原有的手机号和所有现有联系人。借助Mint Mobile的限时优惠摆脱大型无线运营商，
and get premium wireless service for just $15 a month. To get your new unlimited wireless plan for just $15 a month and get the plan shipped to your door for free, go to MintMobile.com slash Smartless. That's MintMobile.com slash Smartless. Cut your wireless build of $15 a month at MintMobile.com slash Smartless. That's MintMobile.com slash Smartless. Cut your wireless build of 15 bucks a month at MintMobile.com slash Smartless. This episode is sponsored in part by CarMax.
以每月仅15美元的价格享受优质无线服务。要以每月仅15美元的价格获取你的全新无限无线套餐，并将套餐免费寄到你家门口，请访问MintMobile.com/Smartless。网址是MintMobile.com/Smartless。每月仅需15美元即可削减你的无线账单，访问MintMobile.com/Smartless。网址是MintMobile.com/Smartless。每月仅需15 bucks即可削减你的无线账单，访问MintMobile.com/Smartless。本集节目部分由CarMax赞助播出。
Look, I don't know about you, but I like to ponder the bigger questions in life like, I don't know, who made the pyramidment? Is there life on other planets? And how much will CarMax pay me for my car? The last one is actually pretty easy. If you're thinking about selling your car and want to know what CarMax will pay for it, just go to CarMax.com. You can get a real offer in two minutes or less.
听着，我不知道你们怎么想，但我喜欢思考生活中一些更大的问题，比如，我不知道，金字塔是谁建造的？别的星球上有生命吗？CarMax会为我的车付多少钱？最后一个其实相当简单。如果你正考虑卖车，想知道CarMax会出价多少，只需访问CarMax.com。你可以在两分钟或更短时间内获得真实报价。
And get this, CarMax gives you up to seven days to accept the offer. Seven whole days, that's enough time to ponder another of life's big questions. Like, what should Sean have for lunch? Tuna. That's car selling reimagined. Car max. Smartless is brought to you in part by all birds.
不仅如此，CarMax给你长达七天的时间来考虑是否接受报价。整整七天，这有足够的时间去思考生活中另一个重大问题。比如，肖恩午餐应该吃什么？金枪鱼。这就是重新构想的汽车销售。CarMax。SmartLess部分由Allbirds赞助播出。
Now, you think like the name all birds that they would be something else, but they're shoes. And you know, way shoes could be homemade from things like you know, found with like, you could build shoes with like, you know, sticks and like the bottom of like bamboo and you could wrap them and stuff like that. But why would you make your own shoes out of natural materials yourself
现在，你听到“Allbirds”这个名字，可能会觉得它们是什么别的东西，但它们其实是鞋子。你知道的，鞋子本可以用各种东西自制，比如你懂的，在野外发现的东西，你可以用木棍和竹子底部之类东西来做鞋子，然后把它们缠绕起来之类的。但你为什么要自己用天然材料做鞋子呢？
when all birds has already perfected the process in the all birds innovation lab? Oh, you got to zip up for that, you got to suit up, you got to zip up. They research how to make the most out of sustainable materials like leather made from plants, sugar cane, and tree fibers. Materials so natural, one might even say they're super natural.
当 Allbirds 的创新实验室里的所有人早已把整个流程做到极致的时候？哦，你得拉上拉链去那儿，你得穿上防护服，把拉链拉上。他们研究如何充分利用可持续材料，比如植物皮革、甘蔗和树木纤维。这些材料如此天然，人们甚至可以说它们是“超自然”的。
Try the plant paste or tree dash or super light to see for yourself how super, super can really get. I wear my alberts every day. I know that sounds like a made up thing, like that scripted, but it's not. I wear them, I walk to the theater in them. They are the most comfortable shoes I've ever had. I swear I wear them every day.
试试植物软鞋（plant paste）、树木快鞋（tree dash）或超轻鞋（super light），亲身体验一下“超级”究竟能达到什么程度。我每天都穿 Allbirds。我知道这听起来像是编出来的，像是有剧本安排的，但真不是。我穿着它们，穿着它们走到剧院。这是我穿过最舒服的鞋子。我发誓我每天都穿。
I got a blue color one, and then another color, I don't know what it is because I'm colorblind. But they go with jeans, they go with everything. And they kind of look better than just regular gym shoes, because you can go out to eat with them instead of gym shoes, you can kind of wear them and they look stylish. So their innovation lab is the home for sciencey stuff like research and testing
我有一双蓝色款的，还有一双别的颜色，我不知道是什么颜色，因为我色盲。但它们跟牛仔裤很搭，跟什么都搭。而且它们看起来比普通的运动鞋要好看一些，因为你可以穿着它们去外面吃饭，而不是只能穿运动鞋，你穿上它们会显得很有型。所以他们的创新实验室就是搞科研的地方，比如研究和测试
renewable materials. That's where they figured out how to craft the plant pacers with leather made from plants, the tree dashes from wood and the super lights from sugar cane. All birds is making shoes better than natural. They're super natural. Find your perfect pair at allbirds.com today
可再生材料。那就是他们琢磨出如何用植物皮革打造植物快步鞋（plant pacers）、用木材打造树木快步鞋（tree dashes）以及用甘蔗打造超轻鞋（super lights）的地方。Allbirds 正在制造比自然更好的鞋子。它们是超自然的。今天就在 allbirds.com 寻找你的完美鞋履吧，
and use code SmartLess for free socks with a purchase of $48 more. That's ALLBIRDS.com code some Martless. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ All right, back to the show. Paul, since we're kind of going through and I want to, there's so many movies we could, you know, because behind every movie,
并在购买 48 美元或以上商品时使用优惠码 SmartLess 获取免费袜子。网址是 ALLBIRDS.com，优惠码是 Smartless。[♪ 片尾音乐响起 ♪] 好了，回到节目中。保罗，既然我们正在经历这些，而且我想……有那么多电影我们可以……你知道的，因为每部电影的背后，
there's a story about making it and stuff like that. I could talk to you for hours about so many things that I love you in. But is there one, because we're kind of like going through them now, is there one that stands out that's really, really, really meaningful to you, that you will, speaking of holding on to things and remembering things that really, really sticks to your soul
都有一个关于它的制作以及类似的故事。我可以跟你聊上几个小时，聊那么多你参演过并且我深爱的作品。但有没有哪一部——因为我们现在差不多正一部部盘点过去——有没有哪一部对你来说格外、极其、极其意义重大，以至于每当谈到铭记事物、留住那些深深烙印在你灵魂深处的东西时，
and you have great memories of. There's a lot of them, I really remember it nicely that way. You know, and it's not necessarily the movie, it's the experience. It's the experience, right? Is there one in particular? There's a movie I did called The Illusionist, which is sort of, it's about a magician and stuff like that. I really liked making that movie. It was in Eastern Europe, it was in Prague, which was fun to be in. And I enjoyed like that. I really liked making that movie. It was in Eastern Europe. It was in Prague,
你对它有着美好的回忆？这样的作品有很多，我确实对它们有着非常美好的记忆。你知道的，这不一定是因为电影本身，而是因为那段经历。是那段经历，对吧？有没有哪一部特别的？我拍过一部电影叫《魔术师》（The Illusionist），大概是讲一个魔术师之类的事情。我真的很喜欢拍那部电影。它是在东欧拍的，在布拉格，在那儿拍戏很有意思。我很享受那种感觉。我真的很喜欢拍那部电影。它是在东欧拍的。是在布拉格，
which was fun to be in. And I enjoyed making that. I wasn't Christopher Nolan, was it? No, it's that's the prestige. Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. At the same time, two magician pictures came in. Yeah, I remember that. I remember that. I mean, I just like working in Prague, man, that is a beautiful time. Great. I loved it. It was fantastic. Yeah, what film do you think, and this would be a very hard thing for you to answer, but what, which film do you think
在那儿拍戏很有意思。我很享受那次拍摄。那不是克里斯托弗·诺兰的片子，对吧？不，那是《致命魔术》（The Prestige）。对。对，对，对。当时有两部关于魔术师的电影同时上映。对，我记得。我记得。我是说，我就是喜欢在布拉格工作，伙计，那是段美好的时光。太棒了。我很喜欢。棒极了。对，你觉得哪部电影——这对你来说可能是个很难回答的问题——但你觉得哪部电影
was the most helpful to you in your career? Because I, I feel like every single job you've done has been extremely prestigious and really, really like, I'm, did, did, will say you've been nominated only once for, for an Oscar? For an Oscar. Yeah, but then, I feel like every single one of us would be like. But like 12 years of slave, Romeo and Juliet saying, Mr. Banks, that would be like.
对你的演艺生涯帮助最大？因为我觉得，你做过的每一份工作都极其声名显赫，而且真的、真的就像……我会说，你只获得过一次奥斯卡提名吗？获得奥斯卡提名。是的，但是，我觉得我们每一个人都会觉得……但是像《为奴十二年》（12 Years a Slave）、《罗密欧与朱丽叶》（Romeo and Juliet）、《大梦想家》（Saving Mr. Banks），那就好像……
It's just, well, those are all I mean, and the 12 years of slave was an amazing movie to me. Yeah, one of those really like it. But any one of those jobs you would think an actor would go, okay, now my career is made. Right, you know. I guess so, but I mean, I think something like. Private parts actually was the first time I ever did anything with real, uh, any- Just for my sister, made, right? You know, I guess so. But I mean, I think something like private parts actually was a first time I ever did
这只是……好吧，这些全都是……我是说，《为奴十二年》对我来说是一部了不起的电影。是的，这是一部真正让人……但你大概会觉得，任何其中那样的工作都会让一个演员觉得，好吧，现在我的职业生涯稳了。没错，你知道的。我想是吧，但我的意思是，我觉得像……
anything with real. Just for my sister Tracy, private parts is the Howard Stern movie about his life, just so we're Howard Howard. It really convincingly and to great claim, plays himself, which is great. He was great. He was so good. He was really great at it. He was, he was terrific.
《私人部分》（Private Parts）其实是我第一次真正参与任何具有真正……等等，为了我妹妹，（事业）有成了，对吧？你知道的，我想是吧。但我的意思是，我觉得像《私人部分》其实是我第一次参与……任何具有真正……（插话：）我得替我妹妹特蕾西（Tracy）说明一下，《私人部分》是霍华德·斯特恩（Howard Stern）关于他生平的电影，所以我们说的就是霍华德·霍华德。他非常令人信服且广受好评地扮演了自己，这太棒了。他演得真好。他太棒了。他在这部戏里真的很棒。他真的很棒，太棒了。
Paul, it does occur to me that private parts actually was a kind of a kicking off point. Of course, you were a working actor, but that kind of opened you up to a halt because it was such a big commercial success. Yeah. I'd only really done theater stuff up until then. I'd done little bit parts and a lot of stuff and a lot of TV shows and TV movies and stuff like that. So that was the first time I had anything substantial to do in a movie. Did that lead to saving private Ryan? I don't remember which one of those came first.
保罗，我确实觉得《私人部分》其实是一个起点。当然，你之前就已经是个职业演员了，但那部电影让你全面打开了知名度，因为它取得了巨大的商业成功。是的，在那之前我基本上只演过戏剧。我演过一些小角色、很多杂七杂八的东西、还有很多电视剧、电视电影之类的。所以那是我第一次在电影中扮演有实质内容的角色。那部电影促成了《拯救大兵瑞恩》（Saving Private Ryan）吗？我不记得这两部哪一部先上映了。
Maybe, but saving private Ryan was years after private parts. I don't, was it? I don't even, this is what's weird. And then this is where I feel like my mind, my brain is going. You're also a guy I bet every single film would love to have you be a part of that film because of what you're a part. I just looked it up. Really? So what it says to the what it says to the community or the industry about what our film is like we have Paul Giamatti in this film. So for sure. Don't even submit your you know this person or
也许吧，但《拯救大兵瑞恩》是在《私人部分》之后好几年。我不知道，是吗？我甚至都……这就是奇怪的地方。然后这就是我觉得我的思维、我的大脑开始出问题的地方。我敢打赌，你也是那种每一部电影都渴望你能参与其中的演员，因为你所代表的……我刚刚查了一下。真的吗？所以这对整个电影界或产业传达出的信号是：我们的电影里有保罗·吉亚玛提。所以毫无疑问。别再向你们投递你认识的这个人或者那个人的简历了……
that person. I appreciate that and I like it, but I don't I don't see it I mean, that's very nice of you to say I feel the same thing about you gentlemen I feel the same way about you don't even try it. No, no I'm not I'm sincere and honest Path protector back there When they say I'm in a movie they're like oh great. It's going straight to video. That's good now We know it's great to video. I've been in plenty of stuff, I've been in plenty of stuff like that, that's for sure.
我很感激，我也很喜欢这样，但我并没有……我是说，你能这么说真是太好了。我对你们几位绅士也有同样的感受，我也有同感——甚至都不用去尝试。不，不，我不是在客套，我是真诚的。后排的这位保护伞（Path protector）当他们说我参演了一部电影时，他们的反应是：“哦太好了，这片子要直接发DVD了。”太好了，现在我们知道这片子要直接发DVD了。我演过不少那种片子，我绝对演过不少那种片子，那是肯定的。
But Paul, you know, what's funny is, and I love, and I feel like there have been all these, through the decades that you've been working in film, there have been all these, like saving private parts, and then in the 2000s, it was sideways, which really, it was so, and I joked that it killed the Merlo business single-handedly. It did, actually.
但保罗，你知道有趣的是——我喜欢，而且我觉得在你在电影界工作的这几十年里，有这么多的作品，就像《私人部分》，然后到了 2000 年代的《杯酒人生》（Sideways），这部电影真的很……而且我开玩笑说它凭一己之力毁了梅洛（Merlot）葡萄酒的生意。确实如此。
But it kind of did, right? It did, yeah. It actually did, I think, yeah. How so? I've seen that movie 50 times. Because of how disparaging you guys talk about Merlo. Yeah. That is sort of like for the Philistines. Yeah. Oh, dude.
但它确实差不多毁了，对吧？确实，是的。实际上真的毁了，我想是的。怎么说？那部电影我看了 50 遍。因为你们对梅洛葡萄酒的贬低。是的。那简直就像是对文盲（Philistines）说的。是的。哦，老兄。
Dude, what? Yeah, what are you talking about? You're even at the mention of Merlot, the look of discussion. The guy goes crazy. Yeah. Yeah. I know, I knew nothing about wine. I know nothing about wine. I don't, you know, you don't drink it. Not particularly now. Yeah. Kind of gives me a headache. What's the drink that you like? What do you like? I like tequila, I like mezcal. Those are the two things that I like a lot.
老兄，什么？对，你在说什么？只要一提到梅洛，你脸上那种嫌弃的表情。那家伙都快疯了。对。对。我知道，我对酒一无所知。我对酒一无所知。我不知道，你知道的，你根本不喝。现在尤其不喝了。对。喝了有点让我头疼。那你喜欢什么酒？你喜欢什么？我喜欢龙舌兰酒（Tequila），我喜欢梅斯卡尔酒（Mezcal）。这是我最喜欢的两种酒。
Is it a pause at a problem? Go ahead, we can talk about it. Yeah, that's hard. Do you really do love it? This shows you I do love it. And this shows you're not a problem. I just still live in the loving, I'm still in the love phase. I'm in the honeymoon phase still with tequila and my scalp.
这算是个问题吗？说吧，我们可以聊聊这个。对，这很难。你是不是真的真的很喜欢它？这说明我是真的很喜欢它。这说明你没什么大问题。我只是还沉浸在热恋中，我和龙舌兰以及梅斯卡尔还处在蜜月期。
So everything's fine. I took a sniff out of somebody's. Somebody had a beautiful glass of tequila on the rocks. Yes, she did. I took a sniff of. I swear to God, I went into a time machine. You never know. By the way, I watched you get in, put his nose in.
所以一切都好。我闻了一下别人的酒。有人拿着一杯漂亮的加冰龙舌兰酒。是的，她拿了。我闻了一下。我发誓，我简直像是坐上了时光机。你永远不知道。顺便说一句，我看着你凑过去，把鼻子凑了上去。
Oh my God. I was knee deep into my 20s. I was feeling pretty fast on a highway. And it was all kinds of things in my pocket. You had a candle on the dashboard. Can't hold the camera down. Paul Jason used to drive with a lit candle on his dashboard. Why?
哦天哪。我当时正处于二十多岁的盛年。我开着车在高速公路上感觉相当飘飘然。我的口袋里装着各种各样的东西。你的仪表盘上还放着一支蜡烛。不能把摄像机放下来。保罗·杰森（Paul Jason）过去常常在仪表盘上点着一支蜡烛开车。为什么？
Because he wanted the cops to stop him so bad. I should have put a co-jack light on my roof. You should have had a Kojak light on my, on my roof. You should have had the little light to just pop up on the roof. Why did you travel to Likana? What was the idea? Just for night time or was it lit all the time? Paul, it was just, I guess I was blind to my douxiness
因为他太想让警察拦下他了。我当时应该在车顶上放一个科贾克（Kojak）警灯。你当时真该在我的……在我的车顶上放一个科贾克警灯。你当时真该在车顶上装那个一按就会弹出来的小灯。你为什么开车去丽卡娜（Likana）？当时是怎么想的？只是为了夜间氛围，还是说它一直点着？保罗，我当时大概是对自己的傻气一无所知，
and I was looking for Atmo, you know? Jason, when you smell that tequila thing and it took me like a time machine, do you, is there like a desire to drink it? Or you're just like, that was nice to smell it, but I don't have any desire. Yeah, no, not anymore, because I did it. And I was thinking about it at the time, I was thinking, let's do this until you're sick
我只是在寻找氛围（Atmo），你知道吗？杰森，当你闻到那种龙舌兰酒的味道，它就像把你带进时光机一样，你会有想喝它的冲动吗？还是你会觉得，闻着挺好，但我一点也没有想喝的欲望？是的，不，没有了，因为我已经喝够了。我当时就在想，让我们一直喝到你对此感到厌烦为止，因为你可不想在四五十岁的时候还在干这种事。
of it because you don't want to be doing this when you're in your 40s or 50s. Oh, that's interesting. Like at the level, at the level at the time. That's what you thought at the time. At the time. Really? You had that foresight to say, I get level, at the level at the time. That's what you thought at the time. At the time. Really? You had that foresight to say, I get it out of the way now. Yeah, I'm going to be honest with you.
哦，那很有意思。就像是当时那种程度。那是你当时的真实想法。当时的真实想法。真的吗？你当时就有这种远见，说我要把这股瘾现在就彻底过完？对，老实跟你说吧。
I'm a little bit too. Whenever I make a cake, I eat so, I'm not kidding. I eat so much of it so that I don't ever want it for a long, long time. It also makes all the cake go away so you can't have any more. So do you, gentlemen, do you drink at all? I don't drink anymore. Will you? I don't know. None of you drink anymore. That's not Sean. No. In a second, Sean, you don't drink. How do I not know that? James, because of, because New Year's Eve, two years ago, all right, the one you got when you're playing games. Sean disappeared. Sean, Sean was doing
我这人也有点……每当我做蛋糕的时候，我吃得……说真的。我吃得超级多，好让我很长很长一段时间都不想再碰它。这也把所有的蛋糕都消灭了，这样你就没法再吃了。那么，各位先生，你们平时喝酒吗？我早就不喝酒了。你会吗？我不知道。你们都不喝酒了。肖恩可不是。不。等等，肖恩，你不喝酒？我怎么会不知道这件事？詹姆斯，因为两年前的除夕夜，好吧，就是你在玩游戏的那次。肖恩失踪了。肖恩……肖恩当时在表演
bit. Paul, this is true. We're at our friends house. And we kept pimping Sean out to do various bits. So he's standing up. It's true. And Sean's doing bits and he's dancing. He's doing all these moves and he's doing impressions of people. And most of the people at the table, like a monkey. But he was hilarious and we're dying.
搞笑桥段。保罗，这是真的。我们在朋友家里。我们不断怂恿肖恩去表演各种搞笑桥段。所以他站了起来。这是真的。肖恩在表演搞笑桥段，他在跳舞。他摆出各种舞姿，还在模仿各种人。桌上的大部分人，就像一只猴子一样。但他太搞笑了，我们都笑得快死过去了。
And then all of a sudden, he wasn't around it. And somebody goes, we're Sean. They went. He went to the hospital. Oh my God. Yeah, yeah, Scotty, you have the hospital. went to the hospital. Oh my God. Yeah, it's Scotty. You have the hospital. You have the hospital.
然后突然之间，他就不见了。有人问：“肖恩呢？”然后他们去看了。他去医院了。哦天哪。对，对，斯科蒂（Scotty），你去了医院。去了医院。哦天哪。对，斯科蒂。你去了医院。你去了医院。
It's just like a competition. I get a fit. I get a fit brought on by alcohol. Oh my God. And so I would just deal with it. I didn't, I wouldn't know when it comes on. Like it would come out once or twice a year. Wait a second.
这就跟比赛似的。我发病了。我因为酒精引发了心脏病发作。哦天哪。所以我只能去应对它。我不知道它什么时候会发作。大概一年会发作一两次。等等。
I was just going to throw it. So you would have it regularly. Yeah. Yeah. Like once or twice a year. And I could be, it goes to his drug. He could be at a party. I could be any I could be a church. He's got his own entrance at Seeders. He's got a special back. So they were
我正要说这个。所以你经常这样发作。对。对。比如一年一两次。而且我当时可能……这成了他的常用路线。他可能在聚会上。我可能在任何地方……我可能在教堂里。他在锡安山医疗中心（Cedars）都有专属入口了。他有一个特别的后门……无论如何，现在吉米·金梅尔（Jimmy Kimmel）叫我“划水桨”（paddles），因为我去过那么多次，他们会……他们会（用除颤仪）清理并让我的心跳恢复正常。是的，然后他从病房给聚会打视频电话。这家伙……我没事。这都在行程计划内。所以你就静静地、静静地自己去了医院。对。对。太美妙了。
back or not and now Jimmy Kimmel calls me paddles because I know so many times they are and they would they would you know clear and get my heart back to right. Yeah, and then he faced time back to the party. This guy's, I'm okay. It's just on schedule here. So you just, you quietly, you just quietly took yourself off to the hospital. Yeah. Yeah. That's beautiful.
（重复/略）
Yeah. The set was done. That's very thoughtful of you. He's been known to, he's been, Paul, he's been known to in the middle of the night. Go to the hospital and not even wake his husband, uh, Scotty up. And then come home and then he tells Scotty the next day that he was at the hospital for a month. Because you've had these heart-buttations. Well, I'm on a cell.
拍戏结束了。你可真体贴。众所周知，保罗，他甚至还有过在半夜三更独自去医院，甚至都不叫醒他的丈夫斯科蒂。然后回到家，第二天告诉斯科蒂他在医院住了一个月。因为你有这些心悸。好吧，我有这个毛病。
It's an atrial fibrillation. What am I supposed to do? He's a hypocondriac. He likes to be taken care of. That doesn't sound like hyper. That sounds like a real thing. No, no, they had his own podcast called hypocondriac. Okay? He's a hypocondriac. Okay. He's a hypochondriac.
这是心房颤动（atrial fibrillation）。我能怎么办？他是个恐病症患者。他喜欢被人照顾。听起来不像是恐病症。听起来像个真毛病。不，不，他自己有个播客节目就叫《恐病症患者》（Hypochondriac）。好吧？他是个恐病症患者。好吧。他是个恐病症患者。
It's, you love it. I understand. I think I used to be one. I'm kind of recovering one. I'm not as bad as I used to. Really? Yes. How'd you get over it? I'm not exactly sure. I think I out, I think I outgrew it. Well, what is a hypochondriac? Like officially, it's somebody who's, who's irrational afraid of germs. No, no, no. Or worried about their health, concerned with their health. Yeah. And a kind of constant monitoring of your health. And making sort of these leaps that they have a sort of a, and I fight again, I think
这病，你很喜欢。我明白。我想我以前也是个恐病症患者。我算是一个正在康复中的恐病症患者。我已经没以前那么严重了。真的吗？是的。你是怎么克服的？我不太确定。我想我是……我想我是随着年龄增长自然摆脱了。好吧，什么是恐病症？官方定义就是那种对细菌有着不理性恐惧的人。不，不，不。或者过度担忧自己的健康、关注自己健康的人。对。而且是对自己的健康进行一种持续的监测。并且会产生这种飞跃性的联想，觉得自己得了某种……而且我再次强调，我觉得
everybody has that and to certain to a certain degree. And I've had to go to jail. Yeah, older you get to, right? And I had this thing recently where I had Jay I was telling you about when we were at any play golf and I was had this sort of pain. I was like, and I'm like, you know what, motherfucker, it's just gas and relax and give yourself a break. Oh, yeah. What was it? A way.
每个人在某种程度上都有这种倾向。而且我不得不去……是的，年纪越大越是这样，对吧？我最近就遇到过这种事，杰伊，就是我之前跟你提过的，我们在打高尔夫球的时候，我身上有这种奇怪的疼痛。我就想，你知道吗，他妈的，这只是胀气而已，放松点，放过自己吧。哦，是真的。那是什么？好家伙。
You're joking. Oh, really? I think in that moment, it just vanished. And I just took it easy for a couple of days and I just like, you know what? Just stop giving it so much fucking credence and stop thinking about yourself and do something. Yeah, but you also said you had a threeminute fart that on the backside of that, you felt great. That is true.
你在开玩笑吧。哦，真的吗？我想就在那一刻，那种感觉就消失了。我只是放松了几天，然后我就想，你知道吗？别再对它赋予那么多他妈的信任了，别老想着自己，去干点别的吧。对，但你也说过，你放了一个持续三分钟的屁，在那之后，你感觉好极了。千真万确。
So if I, if I had hummus, that happens. You have a terrible gas. Just the valve just gets stuck open. Just for the longest one forever. Yeah. I would love to go with you to the Mediterranean somewhere. Just get you into under a hummus diet and watch it all fall apart. I would be, please excuse my friend. I'm so sorry. That's amazing.
所以如果我吃了鹰嘴豆泥（hummus），就会这样。你会有糟糕的胀气。阀门就像卡住了一样。一直放个不停。是的。我很想跟你一起去地中海某处旅游。只要让你开始吃鹰嘴豆泥饮食法，然后看着这一切彻底崩溃。我会……请原谅我的朋友。我太抱歉了。太神奇了。
Paul, I was going to, the other thing I wanted to bring up was, and going through all, and I don't want to go through all your credits, but one of the things, and I've been such a fan of yours for a long time, and I even, and I'm a fan of yours despite the fact that you're friends with the row. And, I've made a lot of deal with the row. Well, we don't have our best friends, but we love to throw as much at them as we can. We really have the best material now. No, that's interesting. Throw it at us.
保罗，我本打算……我想提出的另一件事是——在回顾所有的……我不想回顾你所有的演职履历，但其中有一点，而且我很久以来一直是你的超级粉丝，甚至于……尽管你和罗（Row）是朋友，我依然是你的粉丝。而且，我和罗有过很多交集。好吧，我们不是最好的朋友，但我们很乐意尽可能多地拿他开涮。我们现在确实有最好的段子素材了。不，这挺有意思。冲我们开涮吧。
Beautiful. No, no, no, I haven't seen him in angels. I haven't seen him in a long time. And you're better off. Yeah, probably. I think I probably have to. He, he, he adamantly will not return my calls, my texts, nothing. Does he do this to you guys? You know, you may have a wrong number for him. He's easy. You think so. Pretty good. He likes, he likes contacting connection. He loves doing text bits. You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so?
太美妙了。不，不，不，我好久没见他了。你不见他反倒更好。对，可能吧。我想我大概也得这样。他……他……他坚决不回我的电话、我的短信，什么都不回。他也会对你们这样吗？你知道的，你可能存错他的电话号码了。他这人挺随和的。他挺好的。他喜欢……他喜欢联系和沟通。他很喜欢发短信玩梗。你觉得呢？你觉得呢？你觉得呢？……
You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so?
（重复/略）
You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? You think so? I'm happy to observe, but I then I'm constantly feeling like, oh, God, everyone is contributing and, and, and, emerging and double-click thumbs up. And if you're down with them, and if I don't, I'm a, I'm a dick or I, I hope that people just assume I put my phone down. No, I know.
我很乐意在一旁观察，但我随后又经常觉得，哦天哪，每个人都在参与、在互动、在双击点赞。如果你也加入他们，而我没有，那我就是个混蛋，或者……我希望大家只是以为我把手机放下了。不，我知道。
I know. I put, like, I put my phone down. And so, right? So that they just think I'm not staring, right? Yeah. Yeah. Um, Polly, any, any good, you gotta have one. Oh, is I'm not right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm Paulie. Any any good. You got to have one now. Yeah. Yeah. Paulie.
我知道。我把……就像我把手机放下了。所以，对吧？好让大家以为我不是在盯着屏幕，对吧？对。对。嗯，波利（Polly），有什么……有什么好玩的？你总得有一个吧。哦，我没说错吧。对。对。对。波利，有什么好玩的？你现在总得讲一个吧。对。对。波利。
No, that's fantastic. So that's I want to be a Paulie. No, I don't know. I appreciate it. To give me one good theater story. Just something when Oh, holy long. Here he comes. That's a that's a tough thing. Like, did you ever forget your lines?
不，那太棒了。所以这就是……我想当个波利。不，我不知道。我很感激。给我讲一个精彩的剧院故事吧。就讲那种……哦，霍利·朗（Holy long）。他来了。那可真是个棘手的事情。比如，你有没有忘过词？
Paul? No, I've ever I ever a guy. A guy speaking of heart attacks. A guy I was doing a show once, and a guy, I was in a little black box experimental theater in Seattle where I moved out to Seattle and I started acting out there. And a guy got up in the second row. I was watching him,
保罗？不，我有没有……有个家伙……说到心脏病发作。有一次我正在演一场演出，有个家伙……我在西雅图的一个小型黑匣子实验剧场里，当时我搬到西雅图并在那里开始演戏。第二排有个家伙站了起来。我当时在看着他，
and I was on stage doing this long monologue, 40-minute monologue. Oh my God. And the guy. Doing the monologue and watching the guy. Yeah, I was watching him, and I was on stage doing this long monologue, 40-minute monologue. And the guy. Doing the monologue and watching the guy in the second row? No, I and I in the guy because he was getting really, Dave's getting really dopey looking. And he was like, and I thought something's wrong with this guy. I mean, his close quarters, a little shitty,
我在舞台上做着长篇独白，40分钟的独白。哦天哪。那个家伙……一边演独白一边看着那个家伙？对，我当时在看着他，我在舞台上做着长篇独白，40分钟的独白。那个家伙……一边演独白一边看着第二排的那个家伙？不，我……还有那个家伙，因为他看起来真的……戴夫（Dave）看起来越来越呆滞了。他当时……我心想这家伙有点不对劲。我的意思是，那是个空间逼仄、有点破旧的小型实验剧场。他站起来，跨过前面的人，爬上舞台，然后砰的一声倒在地上，瘫倒了。他突发了……我当时没意识到他心脏病发作了，直到……而且我当时正在剧里扮演……
little experimental theater. And he got up and climbed over the guy in front of him, came up on stage,iston shot himself and dropped He'd had a hearted I didn't realize he'd had a heart attack until and and I was playing in the It was just your performance. I thought well I mean people thought it was just because in the performance I was playing a What you call it the guy who puts his hands, you know, a faithy healer. A healer.
（重复/略）
I was playing a healer. And, you know, and I suck at improving and things like that. I could have been a gold moment for me, but I didn't, but I sort of knelt down and they came up and got the guy off. I heard later, actually years later, I didn't even know that he'd had a heart attack,
我扮演的是一个……你知道的，就是那种给人摸顶治病的所谓“信仰治疗师”（faith healer）。治疗师。我扮演的是一个治疗师。而且，你知道的，我最不擅长即兴表演之类的事情。本来那对我来说可能是一个高光时刻，但我没有，我只是跪了下来，然后有人上台把那家伙抬走了。我后来听说，其实是好几年后我才知道他当时心脏病发作了，
a small heart attack. So, in a way, that's the sound itch on. That's not a great story. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait? Do you evacuate fully? I mean, I'm a little bit of a... Just front-fall, cardiac event, doesn't it? I've never heard about pooling when you have a heart attack. I think maybe it can happen. Well, yeah, you might lose, like, you lose your faculties or whatever. But the guy lives.
是一次轻微的心脏病发作。所以，从某种程度上讲，这就是……（笑声）那不是个好故事。等等，等等，等等……你会有排泄物失禁吗？我的意思是，我是有点……（大笑）仅仅是向前倒下的心脏病发作，也会那样吗？我从未听说过心脏病发作时会大小便失禁。我想也许可能会发生吧。好吧，是的，你可能会失去……比如你失去了对身体的控制力或者别的什么。但那家伙活下来了。
Wait, but the guy lives. That's the whole different thing, though. I think you know. Yes. Well, he was on stage with you. Did he die? He was on stage with me for a while, yeah. That's crazy. I don you know, yes. Yeah, okay. Well, he was on stage with you. Did he, did he? He was on stage with me for a while. Yeah.
等等，但那家伙活下来了。那完全是另一回事了。我想你知道的。是的。好吧，他当时跟你一起在舞台上。他死了吗？他有一会儿跟我一起在舞台上，是的。太疯狂了。我不知道……你知道的，是的。好吧，他当时跟你一起在舞台上。他……他怎么了？他有一会儿跟我一起在舞台上。是的。
I don't know. I don't know if there's anybody who enjoys pooping or talking about it, but it really made me think it says to me today. He says, he goes, he goes, hey, can you play golf on Thursday? I said, no, I can't because I'm getting a colonoscopy on Friday. So Thursday's my prep day. And I said, let me know, I'm going to be at home in that prep phase. I go, let me know if you want to come by and observe. And he wrote very kind. What's the latest to
我不知道。我不知道是不是有人会喜欢排便或者谈论这事，但这真的让我想起了今天发生的事。他说，他说，他说：“嘿，你周四能打高尔夫球吗？”我说：“不行，我周五要做肠镜检查，所以周四周五是我的准备日。”我说：“告诉我一声，我周四会在家里做准备工作。”我说：“如果你想过来观摩的话，随时告诉我。”他写得很客气。最后决定……
let you know? I'm just not sure if my Thursday's going to fill up, you know, I had you with you. Finally, Adlin, did you have it this week? I'm on Friday. Oh, you are. It's actually fantastic. I can tell you I enjoy the hell out of it. It's really, I enjoy it. That little twilight thing they send you off into and you wake up real chatty too. I had a bunch of jokes for the doctor. And then the rest of the day are you, are you exhausted?
什么时候告诉我？我只是不确定周四会不会排满，你知道的，我和你……最后，阿德林（Adlin），你这周做检查了吗？我周五做。哦，你周五做。其实这感觉好极了。我可以告诉你，我简直享受极了。真的，我很享受。就是他们给你用的那种迷幻药（twilight thing），把你送进去，醒来后话还特别多。我当时给医生准备了一堆笑话。然后接下来的那一整天，你……你精疲力竭吗？
No, you're good to go. You feel fresh. I felt very fresh. Paul, I've said this on this podcast a couple of times. You will need a shower, Will. But when I got my colonoscopy and my bare ass is hanging out, right when they put the anesthesia in my arm, they said, count back to 10, I go, 10, nine, or I feel it.
不，你状态很好，随时可以出发。你感觉神清气爽。我感觉神清气爽极了。保罗，我在这个播客节目里说过好几次了。你得洗个澡，威尔。但当我去做肠镜检查、光着屁股露在外面的时候，就在他们把麻醉剂打进我胳膊里的那一刻，他们说：“从 10 开始倒数。”我说：“10，9……”或者我开始有感觉了。
And right when I pass that, I go, whatever you do, don't touch my asshole. And then I pack it up. And you got that out. That all got out. And I heard laughing as I went out. Beautiful. Well, it reminds me of one of my favorite jokes, right? Guy walks into a two, two, a, two, a, two, a, two.
就在我快要失去意识的那一刻，我说：“无论你们做什么，千万别碰我的菊花。”然后我就彻底断片了。你把那话说出来了。你真的把那话说出来了。我走的时候还听到笑声呢。太美妙了。好吧，这让我想起我最喜欢的笑话之一，对吧？一个家伙走进一家……两家……两家……两家……
He's going in my car. He's going in my car. I know that. I think I know the shook. No, complete. Please, please. I like this show too. I think I, I think I leaned over the table and he drops his pants and he's ready for his,
他要钻进我车里了。他要钻进我车里了。我知道那个。我想我知道这个笑话。不，讲完，请讲，请讲。我也喜欢这个笑话。我想我……我想我当时俯身趴在桌上，他脱下裤子，准备接受检查，然后医生进来了，医生说：“好了，别这样，杰瑞，这次别起生理反应（hard on）。”然后病人转过身来说：“我叫安德鲁。”医生说：“我叫杰瑞。”不，这差得远呢，杰森。这他妈太糟糕了。这其实把我给搞糊涂了。把我搞糊涂了。保罗，保罗，保罗，如果你知道的话……这他妈太糟糕了。我很抱歉。这其实把我给搞糊涂了。把我搞糊涂了。
his exam and the doctor comes in and the doctor says, okay, don't, Jerry, this time no hard on. And the patient turns around and he says, my name's Andrew and doctor says, I'm Jerry. No, that's not even close, Jason. That's not fucking terrible. That actually confused me. I was confusing. Paul, Paul, Paul, if you know, I'm fucking terrible. I'm so sorry. That actually confused me. I was confusing.
（重复/略）
Paul, Paul, I was confused. No, I'm confused. It wasn't the joke I thought it was going to be and I'm confused. No, you should know we both got quiet because we wanted to let him hang his up because he has tried to tell this joke 30 times. It's my favorite joke. And it's so embarrassing. On this show or something?
保罗，保罗，我被搞糊涂了。不，我糊涂了。这根本不是我以为要讲的那个笑话，我被搞糊涂了。不，你应该知道我们俩刚才都安静下来了，因为我们想让他自己出丑，因为他已经试过讲这个笑话 30 遍了。这是我最喜欢的笑话。而且太尴尬了。是在这个节目上还是哪儿？
Oh, I want to show him a golf course at dinner and he does it all the time And one time he set up one time he taught it even like this he one time he said he goes And the guy comes in and he says Don't get a heart on Kevin and Kevin says my name's not Kevin I'm gonna go Kevin says Wait, but I think I was conscious of that this time. And I think I said it right. No, I don't think you did.
哦，我想他在高尔夫球场上和晚宴上经常讲这个。有一次他铺垫过……有一次他甚至这样讲：有一次他说，他讲道：“然后那家伙走进来，他说：‘别起生理反应，凯文（Kevin）。’凯文说：‘我叫不叫凯文……’”等一下，凯文说……等等，但我觉得这次我有意识地注意了。而且我觉得我讲对了。不，我觉得你根本没讲对。
The guy's on the table. He was puzzling about that. The guy said, the doctor walks in. The doctor walks in. What happened? The doctor walks in and he says, and the guy says, okay, Jerry, don't get a heart on this time.
那家伙躺在手术台上。他还在琢磨这事呢。那家伙说……医生走进来。医生走进来。然后呢？医生走进来，他说……然后那家伙说：“好了，杰瑞，这次别起生理反应。”
And the patient goes, my name is not Jerry and the doctor goes, no, my name is Jerry. Very good. I just punched it up. I said, I'm throwing extra name in there. I punched it down. I'm confused as to say, I'm Jerry's good. I like just I'm Jerry.
然后病人说：“我不是杰瑞。”医生说：“不，我叫杰瑞。”非常好。我刚刚加工润色了一下。我说，我在里面加了个多余的名字。我把它简化了。我糊涂了，直接说“我是杰瑞”挺好的。我喜欢这种简单的“我是杰瑞”。
That's funny. By the way, leave it to baby and you need it longer and more complicated. And I'm funny. So, Jerry, I'm very funny. That's a funny joke. I have to funny. That's a funny joke. I have to say it's a very funny joke. If you give it a try, it's hard on Jerry and Andrew, who's actually related, who grew up
这挺搞笑的。顺便说一句，留给宝贝（baby）吧，你总把它搞得更长、更复杂。而且我很搞笑。所以，杰瑞，我非常搞笑。这是个搞笑的笑话。我必须得说，这是个非常搞笑的笑话。如果你试着去讲……太难了，杰瑞和安德鲁，他们其实有亲戚关系，他们和杰瑞的表弟一起长大的，他们来自同一个镇子……这就是为什么我们需要编剧。这就是为什么我们需要我们的编剧。难道你们不觉得我们很缺编剧吗？难道你们不需要我们的编剧吗？我们确实很爱我们的编剧。我们确实很爱我们的编剧。是谁把这个笑话讲给你的？你。肖恩。是肖恩把这个笑话讲给你的。所以说到我们的编剧，我最喜欢的一点——这就是我刚才想说的。而且我再次强调，不用多说我也知道我有多么喜欢看你表演。我是你的铁杆粉丝。而且在过去的几年里，我真正
with Jerry's cousin, they went to this, they're from the same town, says, this is why we need our writers. This is why we need our writers. Don't you really feel the lack of writing? Don't you need our writers? We do love her writers. We do love her writers. Who told you that show? You. Sean. Sean told you the joke. So speaking of our writers, one of the things I love, so this is what I was getting at before. And I've again, it goes without saying how much I enjoy watching you perform. I'm a legit fan. And but in the last couple of years, the thing that I've really
喜欢看你表演的作品是《亿万》（Billings）。我觉得那是一部表演极其精彩、完全值得获得更多赞誉的作品。而且有一个……有一个特定的……对于没看过这部剧的人来说，它真的很棒。而且……而且主演是保罗和达米安·刘易斯（Damien Lewis），还有数百万其他优秀的演员。我得有个农场。太棒了。我知道。而且我喜欢……我特别喜欢达米安·刘易斯，我觉得他简直太出色了。他太棒了。
loved watching you is billions. And I think that that is a performance that is so, just deserves so much more acclaim. And there's a, there's a, there's a specific and for people who haven't watched it, it's really great. And it's, and it's Paul and it's Damien Lewis and amongst a million other really. I need to have a farmer. So great. I know. And I love and I love me some Damien Lewis, so I think he's just outstanding. He's great.
（重复/略）
But but you Paul have this moment in the end of one of the seasons where you're left on the bed. I don't want to ruin it. I mean, it's a few years old, but you're left on the bed, and you are crying because it seems like your world has imploded. And as the camera comes around, it reveals that you're laughing. And it was one of the great, I thought it was such a, such an incredible device. It was a device, if you will. Smart episode, yeah. But it was such a nice experience. Fucking brilliant episode. I didn't even see it. it was such a small target for you to hit. Yeah, because an actor would read that in the script and then you'd have to think,
但是……但是保罗，在其中一季的结尾，你有一个镜头是你独自留在床上。我不想剧透。我的意思是，这剧已经播出好几年了，但你独自留在床上，你在哭泣，因为看起来你的世界已经彻底崩塌了。而当镜头绕过来时，却显露出你其实是在笑。那是我认为最伟大的……我觉得这是一个非常、非常不可思议的桥段。如果可以的话，这真是一个绝妙的桥段。非常聪明的一集，是的。但这真是一次美妙的体验。他妈的绝妙的一集。我甚至都没看。这对你来说真是一个很难精准把握的点。是的，因为演员在剧本里读到这段时，你肯定会想：
well, how could I laugh that could believably sound like crying? It was tricky. It's an unfortunate question. Unfortunately, some of it was on my back. That's actually what made some of it easier was it was on my back. So it was like I could do sort of like making it look like I was hunched over laughing or something. But I think actually part of it is too, when I start laughing, I start crying actually. So it actually, it wasn't really, you know, because if I can get, I'm able,
好吧，我该怎么笑才能听起来可信地像是在哭呢？这挺棘手的。这是一个不幸的问题。不幸的是，当时我正趴在背上。事实上，正是这一点让事情变得容易了一些，因为我是趴着的。所以我可以做出那种……看起来像是驼着背在笑或者别的什么动作。但我想其实部分原因也在于，当我开始大笑时，我其实也会开始哭泣。所以实际上，这并不算真的……你知道的，因为如果我能做到这一点，我有能力……
making yourself laugh is tricky. Actually, it can be, but I feel like it's like making a sneeze or something like that. Like it's hard to make it make an authentic sounding sneeze. Yeah. Oh, it is hard to do it. Are you a good cryer? Can you cry on cue? I'm sometimes I'm not necessarily, I'm not one of those people that can do it on cue.
让自己笑出来其实很棘手。实际上，这可能有点难，但我感觉这就像打喷嚏或者别的什么一样。就像很难伪造出一个听起来真实的喷嚏声。是的，哦，这确实很难做到。你是个擅长哭泣的演员吗？你能一秒哭出来吗？我有时……不一定，我不是那种能够说哭就哭的人。
And I'm not one of those people that's like, which eye do you want? Kind of like that. Right. Laura Linnie knows how to do that. Laura Linnie can, oh my god. Where's my mom? I couldn't nail that in a second. Oh, hey,
而且我不是那种会问“你想让我用哪只眼睛流泪”的人。差不多就是那种类型。劳拉·琳妮（Laura Linney）知道该怎么做。劳拉·琳妮可以，哦天哪。“我妈妈在哪儿？”我一秒钟就能搞定这个。哦，嘿，
Paul. Um, but wait a minute. Cause he only had one eye, Paul. Uh, but wait a minute. Did she have tears out of the fake eye? Oh, fake eye. I would know. The tears were the two were the duck. That one came with a pump that she put in her head. Yeah, it's a hole in her head. Did she lose? I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
保罗。嗯，等一下。因为她只有一只眼睛，保罗。嗯，等一下。她那只假眼能流出眼泪吗？哦，假眼。我怎么会知道。眼泪是……那两滴是泪腺分泌的。那只眼带有一个她装在脑袋里的泵。是的，她脑袋上有个洞。她……对不起，对不起。
Did she lose the eye in somewhere? It's just two. When she was two years old, she. I'm sorry. Did she lose the eye in somewhere? Yes, she is too. When she was two years old, she'd cancer. And she found it and brought it to the show. We actually had, we both, we've all three of us have held her eye. We did it on stage. Mm-hmm.
她是在哪里失去这只眼睛的？那是她两岁的时候……对不起，她是在哪里失去这只眼睛的？是的，她两岁时。她得了癌症。然后她把眼球取出来带到了节目现场。我们其实……我们三个都拿过她的眼球。我们在舞台上这么做过。嗯哼。
Her was constant. Actually, I am formaldehyde. That's not galasii. I see. I hear galasii. Wow. That's amazing. Paul, do you, is there like a, do you, are you somebody who seeks out, like, develop things for themselves?
她的眼球一直都是……其实，那是保存在福尔马林里的。那不是玻璃制（galasii）的。我懂。我听到你说玻璃制（galasii）了。哇。太神奇了。保罗，你……是不是那种会主动寻求、为自己开发项目的人？
Are you just an actor who's just like, you know what, my agent just call me when there's something that you feel is right? Otherwise, I'm not going to go find a writer, put this thing together, right? It was more of that kind of thing for a long time. I made some like, not on successful attempts to produce some stuff, not even necessarily stuff for me to be in, and I managed to make some movies, and I did a television show that I then appeared
还是说你只是个演员，觉得“你知道的，等有合适的项目时让我的经纪人打电话给就行了”？否则你才不会去找编剧把项目凑到一起，对吧？很长一段时间里，我确实更偏向于后一种。我做过一些……不能算是不成功的尝试去制作一些东西，甚至不一定非得是我参演的东西，我确实设法制作了一些电影，我还做过一部电视剧，然后我在里面客串了，
in called Lodge 49 that nobody watched, and it's a nice show. Oh, yeah, tell me about that show. It's a really good show. It's a really good show. And yeah, it was on for two seasons on AMC, and nobody watched it, but it was really good show. It's a really good show. And yeah, it was on for two seasons on AMC and nobody watched it, but it was a good show. And just because the writer, I met the guy
名叫《圣殿春秋》（Lodge 49），虽然没人看，但那是一部不错的剧。哦，对了，跟我讲讲那部剧。那是一部非常好的剧。那是一部非常好的剧。是的，它在 AMC 播了两季，虽然没人看，但它确实是一部好剧。那是一部非常好的剧。是的，它在 AMC 播了两季，没人看，但它确实是一部好剧。而且就因为编剧……我遇到了那个家伙，
and I read the thing and thought, wow, somebody should help this guy make this thing because it's really great. But I haven't only lately now, and as I finished billions, I've actually been doing a podcast because for the past couple of months. Which I can get to, yeah.
我读了剧本，心想，哇，真的应该有人帮这个家伙把这东西拍出来，因为它太棒了。不过直到最近，随着《亿万》杀青，在过去的几个月里，我其实一直在做一档播客节目。我可以接着说，是的。
And that was something that I did develop with a guy that I know was a philosopher and there's animation and stuff like that. That's kind of the first thing that I feel like I really did on my own. That's cool. podcast is chin wagging. It's called chin wag. Yeah.
那是我和一个我认识的哲学家共同开发的节目，里面还有动画之类的内容。我觉得这差不多是我第一次真正完全靠自己做的事情。那挺酷的。那个播客叫《闲聊瞎扯》（Chinwag）。它叫 Chinwag。是的。
Chinwag chinwag. What does that mean? What is a chinwag? It's like a, I think it's a British term for like just shooting the shit. I've never heard of it. Yeah. mean, what is it, Chen Wag? It's like a, I think it's a British term for like just shooting the shit. I never heard that. Yeah. Wagging the shit back.
Chinwag，Chinwag。那是什么意思？什么是 Chinwag？这就像是一个……我想这是一个英国俚语，意思是闲聊天、胡侃。我从来没听说过。是的。我是说，什么是 Chinwag？这就像是一个……我想这是一个英国俚语，意思是闲聊天、胡侃。我从来没听说过那个词。对。把废话来回甩（Wagging the shit back）。
But you get, and it's a, it's a comedy podcast, but you, you get into all sorts of different areas you got, you talk about UFOs and ghosts and big foot and shit like that. I'm in, I'm in. I'm in. Yeah, because I like stuff like that. And I was like, you know what? I'm tired and I'm tired of not talking about big foot and doing shit about UFOs and ghosts. Yeah, yeah.
但这节目……这是一个喜剧播客，但你们会聊到各种不同的领域，你们会谈论 UFO、鬼魂、大脚怪（big foot）之类的话题。我加入，我加入。我加入。是的，因为我喜欢这类东西。我就想，你知道吗？我累了，我厌倦了不谈论大脚怪，不聊 UFO 和鬼魂这些破事。对，对。
Do you watch ancient aliens? I do watch ancient aliens. I love it. I love that joke. I love it. What about how the universe works? I've known. I haven't seen that.
你看《远古外星人》（Ancient Aliens）吗？我看《远古外星人》。我太喜欢了。我喜欢那个笑话。我太喜欢了。那《宇宙是如何运行的》（How the Universe Works）呢？我没看过。我没看过那个。
What's ancient aliens? Yeah, what is ancient aliens? What's your channel? It's on the history channel. It's what it is. It's all about conspiracy theories about like why civilizations just died out like the Mayans is like, right, or the Egyptians. It's like all the stuff happens and then it's just done. It's like, chariot to the gods. It's all about UFOs, visited Earth back in the day and it built the pyramids
什么是《远古外星人》？对，什么是《远古外星人》？你在哪个频道看的？在历史频道（History Channel）播的。就是那个。它讲的全都是阴谋论，比如像玛雅人这样的文明为什么会突然消亡，对吧？或者是埃及人。就好像所有这些事情发生了，然后就突然结束了。就像埃里希·冯·丹尼肯（Erich von Däniken）的《众神的战车》（Chariots of the Gods）。讲的都是 UFO 曾在远古时期访问过地球并建造了金字塔。
and all this kind of thing. And they took out. And we have legitimate people sort of espousing on these theories and yeah, fairlyly, fairly legitimate. Is that a degree you can get fairly legitimate? Do you? History channel level. Shatter actually was on it. Was Shatter on Ancient Ali? Oh, okay, I mean, yes, he was. He wasn't. And we actually talk, I talk to Shatter. He was a captain of a spaceship, so yeah, he's quite legitimate.
诸如此类的事情。他们拿出来。我们有一些正经人开始支持这些理论，而且说实话，还挺像那么回事的。这是能拿到学位的正经学问吗？是吗？历史频道级别的。夏特纳其实还真上过。夏特纳上过《远古外星人》吗？哦，好吧，我是说，对，他上过。他没上过。其实我们聊过，我和夏特纳聊过。他以前是个飞船船长，所以对，他相当正经。
Yeah, Paul, do you, so what have you, what have you gleaned from these episodes about, say, for instance, UFOs? Are they, what's, what's your feeling about it? What's going on? Well, I'm a believer. I've never seen anything like this. I'm a believer. And stuff is super weird now. I mean, all the weirdness now of the government saying they exist. They just opened up a new division. They just did, yeah. They did, but I'm confused.
对，保罗，你——那么你从这些剧集里，比如关于UFO，都琢磨出什么了？它们是——你对这事有什么感觉？到底怎么回事？好吧，我是个信徒。我从来没见过这种东西。我是个信徒。而且现在这事变得超级诡异。我是说，现在政府承认它们存在的这种诡异感。他们刚刚成立了一个新部门。他们确实刚成立，对。他们是成立了，但我很糊涂。
It's like, on the one hand, a bunch of guys say they're real and then they walk that back very quickly and it's really confusing. And NASA just, is it a NASA that they just opened up a new thing? I don't know. Some, Jason's right. I read that too. There's some part of the government is opening a new, they're doing, I know that. And if it had any been happened to him.
就好像，一方面有一群人说它们是真的，然后他们又很快改口，这真的让人很迷惑。而且NASA刚刚——是NASA吗，他们刚成立了一个新机构？我不知道。有——贾森是对的。我也读到过。政府的某个部门正在成立一个新机构，他们在搞这个，我知道。如果这事发生在他身上。
If they were, if they were really curious about it, I would think they would not tell us. They would let us know when they were done. You would think. You know, but don't the intelligence community. It's up though. We had Neil the Grass Tyson on our show, ages ago, right? Well, one of the first episodes we did and he made the point that if these things, these supernatural or extraterrestrial visits or all these things were actually
如果他们——如果他们真的对这好奇的话，我想他们不会告诉我们。他们会在搞清楚之后才让我们知道。你本来会这么想的。你知道，但是情报部门难道不——不过这事确实发生了。我们很久以前就在节目里请过尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森，对吧？好吧，那是我们早期做的一期节目，他提出过一个观点：如果这些东西——这些超自然或地外访客，或者所有这些事情——真的
occurring, we live in a time where people take something like a billion photographs a day and videos pointed in every direction. And yet there's no because they don't, because they don't want to be lots of actual. There's lots of videos that they can. They are. They may be in the early days. Well, the Navy. The Navy videos are pretty. But don't you think we live in a world now too that if it was, if there was actual proof,
在发生的话，我们生活在一个人们每天拍大约十亿张照片、视频指向四面八方的时代。然而却没有——因为他们不——因为他们不想留下大量真实的证据。有很多视频他们可以——它们是。它们可能在早期。好吧，海军。海军的视频相当——难道你不觉得我们也生活在这样一个世界里吗：如果有真正的证据，
you could hide it. That people, people, no, well, no, I don't, I think we live in a culture now where people would be like, yeah, that's kind of cool. Anyway, what are you guys doing? Yeah, they could give it. Don't give it shit. Well, I see. It would just get buried in the avalanche,
你是藏不住的。人们，人们——不，好吧，不，我不这么觉得，我觉得我们现在生活在这样一种文化中：人们会觉得，“哦，这挺酷的。总之，你们在干嘛？”对，他们才不在乎呢。好吧，我明白。它只会淹没在那些源源不断的
a shit that's out there all the time. So we just end up as just like a really non-consequential, like TikTok, like, I was my family this weekend and we saw a UFO. Yeah. You know, in that mechanical voice. I love when I stumped that smart scientist to grass Tyson on my whole mirror.
垃圾信息的雪崩之中。所以我们最终只会把它当成一个毫无关联的东西，就像TikTok一样，比如：“我这周末和家人在一起，然后我们看到了一个UFO。”对。你知道，用那种机械的语音。我喜欢我把我那个聪明科学家朋友德格拉斯·泰森给问得哑口无言的时候。
How'd you do that? Oh, you should have. No, backhand, listen, It's a real great listen. Yeah, Jason really did you tell him the hard on joke and see if he understood it? I did not hear you go. So I just give you a good figure this one out. Who's named Kevin and who's Andrew smart man?
你是怎么做到的？哦，你真应该——不，说真的，听着，这是一段非常精彩的对话。对，贾森，你真的——你有没有跟他讲那个硬汉笑话，看他听不听得懂？我没有——听着。所以我只是——你好好琢磨琢磨这个。谁叫凯文，谁是安德鲁，聪明人？
Jason was trying to figure out what he was trying to figure out about figuring out if you could. Time travel. If you put a mirror far enough away, could you see? It was about the speed of light. The speed of light. And would you be able to see? But the question was so long and involved.
贾森当时正试图弄明白——他正试图弄明白能不能——时光倒流。如果你把一面镜子放得足够远，你能看到吗？这跟光速有关。光速。然后你能看到吗？但那个问题太长太复杂了。
You've seen Neil deGrasse Tyson, who is a big brain guy. He's got a lot of stuff. He's glazing and really becoming quite confounded. And then he got it. And if you see him, because you're getting angry that he's almost angry. He's almost angry. And at which point I said, I said,
你见过尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森，他是个脑子很大的人。他知道很多东西。他开始发懵，真的变得相当困惑。然后他懂了。如果你看到他——因为你开始生气了，他简直快生气了。他简直快生了。就在那时我说，我说：
Neil, do you think that they could build a telescope big enough that you could go back in time through mirrors to see the beginning of Jason's question? Nice. That he liked. We earned him back on that. We earned him back. There we go.
“尼尔，你觉得他们能造出一个大到可以通过镜子回到过去、看到贾森那个问题开端的望远镜吗？”太棒了。他挺喜欢这个的。我们在那点上把他拉回来了。我们把他拉回来了。就是这样。
So I'm so into that Paul. So billions is. Yeah, take a listen to it. We earned a back. Very good. So, you still ended that, Paul? So billions is, yeah, take a listen to it. Billions is over. Yeah, yes, it is. Now it's ending. Yeah, we trust it. Now I said, because you guys kind of, you stuttered, stopped, you stopped, and then you guys did another season.
我对这个太感兴趣了，保罗。所以数十亿是——对，听听看。我们把他拉回来了。很好。所以，你还是结束了，保罗？所以数十亿是——对，听听看。数十亿结束了。对，是的，它结束了。现在它结束了。对，我们相信它。现在我说，因为你们有点——你们磕磕绊绊地停下了，然后你们又拍了另一季。
Is that kind of how we had a, well, the COVID thing, you know, shut everything down. And so we had in the middle of the fifth season, and then we finished that half and the sixth, and then we just did the seventh and now it's the seventh. Wow, good for you. Was that a great, a good, positive experience working in New York? Yeah, yeah, it was great. I mean, I was 15 minutes from my house here in Brooklyn,
你们是这样——我们有——好吧，新冠这事儿，你知道，把一切都叫停了。所以我们在第五季中途停播了，然后我们拍完了那一半和第六季，接着我们又拍了第七季，现在就是第七季。哇，真为你高兴。在纽约工作是一段很棒、很积极的经历吗？对，对，太棒了。我是说，离我在布鲁克林的家只有15分钟路程，
which was great. And it was nice I could be around my kid, he was a teenager and all of that was great. And the people were great. There was no assholes anywhere on it. It was great. That's great. Yeah, man, it. Yeah. You know,
这太棒了。而且能陪在我的孩子身边也很好，他当时是个青少年，所有这些都很棒。而且大家都很棒。剧组里没有一个混蛋，太棒了。太棒了。对啊，伙计，它——对。你知道，
I always say if you if you look around, you can't find the asshole on a set. It's probably you. Yeah. You do say that. You do say that once a day. I'm looking for this reminder me my colonoscopy. It's all about my asshole. Yeah. You know, great. We had to bring it all back, guys. We have a classic guest with us today. What are you doing when you're not asking? What are you doing like to fill fill the time and the god? It's like you're reading that yeah No, I'm just running out of more robotic puller. What do you do when you're not? No, because I want to know because I know you're doing the podcast, but like what I do the podcast now and I and I really I read a lot. I don't know. I it's a little bit like I'm kind of I don't have a job now and I am a little anxious about it. Because I am a little bit I think of a work of all like what will you do for the summer?
我总是说，如果你环顾四周，在片场找不到混蛋，那可能你就是那个混蛋。对。你确实这么说。你一天到晚都这么说。我正找这个呢，提醒我做肠镜。全都是关于我的屁股。对。你知道，太好了，我们得把话题都扯回来，伙计们。我们今天来了一位经典嘉宾。你不拍戏的时候在干嘛？你用什么来打发时间，天哪——你好像在照着念——不，我只是快没词了，像个机器人一样。保罗，你不拍戏的时候在干嘛？不，因为我想知道，因为我知道你在做播客，但是——我现在的确在做播客，而且我——我读很多书。我不知道，这有点像——我现在没有工作，我对此有点焦虑。因为我有点——我觉得自己是个工作狂，比如说你夏天要干什么？
Like again, I have to do the podcast is to do the podcast. Yeah. And then and then I don't know this is what you walk across the you walk across the Brooklyn bit. This is what Iummixed. You walk across the Brooklyn bit. This is what I imagine your day is. You walk across the Brooklyn bridge, you go get coffee, you go to the strand. You might meet somebody for lunch, you walk back,
就像我说的，要做播客，就要做播客。对，然后——然后我不知道，这就是你走过——你走过布鲁克林大桥。这就是我脑补的。你走过布鲁克林大桥，你去买杯咖啡，你去斯特兰德书店。你可能会跟某人见面吃午饭，你走回去，
you'll take a nap, you'll go for dinner, maybe you'll go to Williamsburg. That's actually pretty accurate. That's terrifyingly accurate. It's actually pretty close. The thing that is very nice of what you do is that you work all the time so that we get to watch you.
你会小睡一会儿，然后去吃晚饭，也许你会去威廉姆斯堡。这实际上挺准的。这准得吓人。实际上非常接近。你做得很好的一点是，你一直在工作，所以我们能经常看到你。
I love that I can count on you being in something once a year at least. You know, like I hate these great high quality actors that are like so goddamn like I only want to work you know once every five years. But they're picky. That's not a bad thing. You're very picky, though, too. It's just, I feel like you, uh, I think there's been more things that you haven't, that you haven't treated yourself to watching that I've done,
我喜欢我能指望你每年至少参演一部作品。你知道，就像我讨厌那些了不起的高质量演员，他们总是该死的摆出一副“我只想每五年工作一次”的样子。但他们很挑剔。这不是坏事。不过你也很挑剔。只是，我觉得你——我觉得有些你没让自己去看我拍的东西，
whether or not, not if I'm not at the highest quality. There's no, I know you're being very modest, but I'm not, I should, should have been picky here and so on. You know, you're being very modest, and I will say, and I think what Jason is getting at is that you are, when, if I look at a film or a show that's coming out of some, and I see Paul, your name, I'm like, all right, this thing has a certain,
不管它们是不是最高水准的。没有，我知道你很谦虚，但我也——我本该在那儿挑剔的，诸如此类。你知道，你太谦虚了，我要说的是，我想贾森的意思是，当你——如果我看一部上映的电影或剧集，看到保罗你的名字，我就会想：好吧，这东西有某种——
they know it. I mean, good day. Yeah, it's true. It's a true, now, saying that, here are the list of things that you've done that I have not liked. No, right. Yeah.
他们懂的。我是说，好日子。对，这是真的。这是真的，话说回来，以下是你拍过但我并不喜欢的作品清单。不，好吧。对。
As we like to hand the show, and I'm going to have to go alphabetical because the list is low. No, no, but, Paul, but I was going to say you've done so many things and we often ask people here, we're like, oh, what have you done? You've done a lot of this, you've done a lot of that, what would you like to do? I mean, you've kind of done comedy, you've done drama, you've done period, you've done a lot of this, you've done a lot of that. What would you like to do? I mean, you've kind of done comedy, you've done drama, you've done period. You've explored a lot of areas as an actor.
正如我们喜欢在节目里开玩笑的，我得按字母顺序来，因为清单太长了。不，不，但是，保罗，不过我想说的是，你拍过太多东西了，我们经常在这里问别人，我们会问：哦，你都拍过什么？你拍过这个，拍过那个，你还想拍什么？我是说，你演过喜剧，演过剧情片，演过年代戏，你拍过很多这个，拍过很多那个。你还想拍什么？我是说，你演过喜剧，演过剧情片，演过年代戏。你作为演员探索过很多领域。
Is there one zone that you feel really comfortable in that excites you still? Well, I'd like to do more theater. That would be nice. I would like to do goofier comedic stuff. I used to do a long time ago and I definitely got into doing something like that in a long time. It's not comfortable necessarily doing that at all. But I bet not winking though, right? I bet like authentic sort of like Cohen Brothers type of eccentric characters that are very funny,
有没有哪个领域让你觉得真正感到舒适、并且依然让你感到兴奋？嗯，我想演更多戏剧。那倒挺不错的。我想演一些更滑稽的喜剧。我很久以前演过，而且我绝对很久没去演过那种类型的东西了。演那种角色其实并不一定让人觉得舒服。但我觉得不是那种带有调侃意味的，对吧？我指的是那种原汁原味的、科恩兄弟风格的、非常搞笑的怪诞角色，
but they don't know they're funny. Yes, that would be nice. Something like that. What if you want to wink, man? No. What if you and the not-winking? And Lincoln would be like, what do you mean? Like, super, super broad and soft-mooric and you're overqualified for that. You think so?
但他们自己并不知道自己很搞笑。是的，那倒挺不错。类似那样的。要是你想带点调侃呢，老兄？不。要是你不用那种调侃呢？调侃的意思就像是：你是什意思？就像是——超级、超级夸张和滑稽，而你对这种角色来说太大材小用了。你觉得是吗？
I don't know. Super broad and soft-mooric. Do you guys still love to perform on film and TV? Do you still love it? Do you still feel like it gives you the thing and always gave you, do you feel? It's just a good question. I was gonna ask you the same thing.
我不知道。超级夸张和滑稽。你们还喜欢在电影和电视里表演吗？你们还喜欢吗？你们还觉得它能带给你一直以来都有的那种感觉吗？这是一个好问题。我正想问你同样的问题呢。
It's a good question. I'm curious. It's like, I just love a set. I just think it's, I'm so comfortable on a set. I love how many people it takes to make something. I grew up on a set. I know, but I didn't know then how complicated it is to make fake life and how many people you need to actually get it done.
这是一个好问题。我也很好奇。这就好像，我就是喜欢片场。我只是觉得，我在片场感到非常自在。我喜欢制作一件作品需要这么多人。我是在片场长大的。我懂，但我当时并不了解创造虚假的生活有多么复杂，以及你需要多少人才能真正把这事搞定。
You know that it's not just the love it. And you love the process of it, and all that. More than the product. Uh-huh. I get that. You know, to answer your question for me, I think at this age, it really now finally for the first time in my life, it really, really matters what it is.
你知道不仅仅是喜欢它。而且你喜欢它的整个制作过程，诸如此类。比起成片来说更是如此。嗯。我懂。你知道，回答你的问题，对我来说，我觉得在这个年纪，终于在我人生中第一次，它真的、真的很重要——到底是什么作品。
Because if I'm gonna spend all that time, energy resources, all of it, I'm gonna give 110%, and if it works, right? If it doesn't work great, that's fine, but as long as I believe in it, I think that's my answer. I feel the same way.
因为如果我要花那么多时间、精力、资源，所有的这一切，我要付出110%的努力，如果它成功了，对吧？如果不成功也没关系，那倒无所谓，但只要我相信它，我想这就是我的答案。我也是这么觉得的。
I feel like, yeah, and life and kids, and also just sort of feeling content on a day to day basis is I put such a premium on that. And being happy, I put such a premium rather than on work. And the last couple of years, I have not really done anything. I have not said yes to anything in a long time until this year.
我觉得，是的，生活和孩子，还有仅仅是在日常生活中感到满足，我把这看得极其重要。保持快乐，我把这看得比工作还要重要。在过去的几年里，我其实什么都没做。直到今年以前，我很久没有对任何事情说过“好”了。
And that feels good, that's felt good. It feels really good. And there were things I maybe should have done, but I was just like, ah, I just didn't feel. But you don't regret it. No, and luckily I was doing other stuff, and so I could continue to make a living and could afford to say no, but I just wasn't feeling it.
这感觉很好，感觉真的很不错。而且有些事我本该去做的，但我当时就觉得：啊，我就是没那种感觉。但你不后悔。不，幸运的是我当时在做别的事，所以我能继续维持生计，也付得起说“不”的代价，但我就是没那种感觉。
I mean, you know, and Jay, I know that you feel, well, because you're doing so much more directing and you've had the opportunity again, I don't want to speak for you, but it's as an observer that you do a lot of, like, I don't want to do, you just want to do this stuff that excites you. Yeah, yeah, I want to be,
我是说，你知道，而且，贾森，我知道你的感受，因为你现在做了更多导演工作，而且你再次有了机会——我不想替你说话，但作为一个旁观者，你做了很多，就像——我不想做，你只想做那些让你兴奋的事情。对，对，我想——
I really like being challenged because I know there's gonna, I've had enough periods in my life where I'm not confident or I'm not feeling up to a challenge and I know those times will occur again. So while I'm feeling eager to take off possibly more than I can handle,
我真的很喜欢接受挑战，因为我知道——我人生中已经经历过足够多的时期，那时我缺乏自信，或者觉得自己无法应对挑战，我知道这样的时期还会再次出现。所以，当我渴望承担可能超出我能力范围的事情时，
I want to take advantage of those moments. Right. Yeah. Because I know I'm going to be a coward later again. Paul, what about you? The same question to you. Yeah, no, I think I feel a lot of the same things that you guys were just saying. But I feel like I'm a little bit in the place that you are, Wilbur. It's like I think I just want to, I didn't use, and all of you guys, I mean, I just want to do the thing that is really gonna matter because it's otherwise, I don't have the energy, I'm old, I'm gonna be old, man.
我想好好利用这些时刻。对。对。因为我知道我以后又会变成一个懦夫。保罗，你呢？同样的问题问你。对，不，我想我的感受和你们刚才说的很多东西都差不多。但我觉得我有点处于你那种状态，威尔。就好像我觉得我只是想——我以前没用过，还有你们所有人，我是说，我只想做那些真正重要的事情，因为除此之外，我没有精力了，我老了，我快老了，老兄。
And it's like, I'm just, it's like, so I have to just, it's gotta be something I really, really wanna do. But it's been interesting doing other things too. It's like, I would like to draw again. I would like to try to write. I don't know if I can fucking read all the fucking time, but I don't know if I can write something.
这就好像是，我只是，就好像是，所以我必须得，那一定得是我非常非常想做的事。不过尝试做点别的事也挺有意思的。就好像，我还想再画画。我想尝试写作。我不知道自己能不能他妈的整天都在看书，但我不知道自己能不能写出点东西来。
I would like to try different things. So I think I need to say no more, and I think I need to just do the things I wanna do, for sure. Well, how about this, when you're done with your walk across the bridge to get the coffee in the dinner, like Will, you write a couple pages. I would try. I think you to get the coffee in the dinner, like Will, sat in the usual, right, a couple of pages. I would try.
我想尝试不同的事情。所以我觉得我需要拒绝更多，而且我确信我需要只做我想做的事。好吧，这样吧，当你走过桥去餐厅买咖啡的时候，就像威尔一样，你写几页纸。我会试试的。我想你去餐厅买咖啡，就像威尔一样，坐在老地方，写几页纸。我会试试的。
I think you should do. You should get over there to the Bolasco theater and see Shawnee and Good Night Oscar. I would like to see you. I would very much like to see that. I'm going to get you some house. I would very much like to see that. I would love to see that. I would love to see that.
我认为你应该去。你应该去博拉斯科剧院看肖妮和《晚安，奥斯卡》。我很想看你演。我非常想看那个。我会给你安排个座位。我非常想看那个。我很想看那个。我很想看那个。
I would love to see that. Here's what's going to happen. I'm headed east at the end of this week and I'm going to come to the city. We're going to go and have dinner or we're going to have lunch. I would love that. Downtown. And then we're going to talk about what you're going to write. Yeah, I would love it. And for 3% will you be offering his agent thing for 3%?
我很想看到那个。接下来会发生这样的事：这周末我要往东走，我要去市区。我们要去吃晚饭，或者我们要吃午饭。我很乐意。在市中心。然后我们要谈谈你要写什么。是的，我很乐意。为了百分之三，你会为他的经纪人提供百分之三的待遇吗？
No, I know, I'm just going to help him. It's going to be his idea and I want to write. That actually would be right. I would welcome that. That would help me. It would help me. I need help. Conversations get ideas going for himself. So he doesn't need my help. He will help me. Yeah would help me. I need help. Conversations is get ideas going for himself. So you just need my help. You just offering your muse and amuse muse muse for hire.
不，我知道，我只是要去帮他。这会是他的主意，而且我想写作。那实际上是对的。我会欢迎的。那会对我有帮助。那会对我有帮助。我需要帮助。对话能为他自己产生灵感。所以他不需要我的帮助。他会帮我的。是的，会帮我的。我需要帮助。对话能为他自己产生灵感。所以你只需要我的帮助。你只是在提供你的灵感女神和供人消遣的缪斯，一个供雇用的缪斯。
Why don't you call it Paul? Why don't you call it moth catcher? I like it. I like it too. Moth catcher. Fantastic. That's a start. That's a great start. Moth protector. Does that what I call the protector of the catcher? That. What's a math tracker? What's a math tracker? Math tracker. Math tracker. Math tracker. Math tracker. Math tracker.
你为什么不叫它保罗呢？你为什么不叫它捕蛾器呢？我喜欢。我也喜欢。捕蛾器。太棒了。这是一个开始。这是一个美好的开始。护蛾者。捕蛾者的守护者是这么叫的吗？那个。什么是数学追踪器？什么是数学追踪器？数学追踪器。数学追踪器。数学追踪器。数学追踪器。数学追踪器。
That's a math tracker. What was the last book that you read that really, that you were excited about, that you really liked? Do you remember? I read a lot of like crappy mysteries. Do you? I read a lot of crappy thrillers and crappy mysteries and spy novels. Oh, I read a lot of stuff like that.
那是一个数学追踪器。你读过的上一本让你真正兴奋、真正喜欢的书是什么？你还记得吗？我读了很多垃圾悬疑小说。是吗？我读了很多垃圾惊悚小说、垃圾悬疑小说和间谍小说。哦，我读了很多那样的书。
I read a lot of stuff like that. That's the funny thing. Oh, I love spy novels. I do too. I read a lot of stuff like that. That's the funny thing. I don't read much hype out stuff, actually. I read a lot of spy novels. Yeah, I enjoy that stuff a lot. I really like that. Do you ever read any of those lend Dayton books?
我读了很多类似的书。这就是有趣的地方。哦，我喜欢间谍小说。我也是。我读了很多类似的书。这就是有趣的地方。其实我不太读那些炒作出来的书。我读了很多间谍小说。是的，我很喜欢那些东西。我真的很喜欢。你读过列恩·戴顿的书吗？
You know, that's what I just read. Actually, I was going to say what I just read was a fucking lend Dayton book. I'm a penny. It is a penny. And so the Bernhardt the Bernie Gunther series, right? Yeah. So I read all nine of those. Yeah. A couple of some of you guys. Yeah, those are great. I can see. We are. We are. I just read a
你知道的，我刚刚读到的就是这样。其实，我本想说我刚读的实际上是一本伦·戴顿的书。我真是一文不名。确实如此。所以是伯恩哈德，也就是伯尼·冈瑟系列，对吧？是的。所以我把那九本都读了。是的。你们中的一些人也读过一些。是的，那些都很棒。我能看出来。我们是。我们是。我刚刚读了一本
good. You would be a great fucking Bernie Gunther. I wouldn't. That's the clown sitting on the on the on the Brooklyn bridge. He's with I'm sitting on a on a Brooklyn bridge He's with a book sitting on a bench right We're talking to each other No, no Like some great old couple So if you love those
很好。你非常适合演该死的伯尼·冈瑟。我不适合。那是那个坐在布鲁克林大桥上的小丑。他和一个...我坐在布鲁克林大桥上，他拿着一本书坐在长椅上，对吧？我们正聊着呢。不，不，就像某些了不起的老两口一样。所以，如果你喜欢那些
Lendite, I've got another Series for you I'll bring them a book That would be fun That would be lovely That would be lovely I'm going to Yeah, by the way
兰迪特，我为你准备了另一个系列，我会给他们带一本书，那会很有趣，那会很棒，那会很棒，我要去，顺便说一句
Please Paul, what now what are we What are we looking at Just before we let you go? What are we looking at for the summer? If everything is kind of shut down, are you gonna hit the beach? Are you gonna get in the water? Are you gonna, what are you gonna do?
请问保罗，我们现在面对的是什么？在我们放你走之前，夏天我们该期待什么？如果一切都处于封锁状态，你还要去海滩吗？你要下水吗？你要——你打算做点什么？
I can't do you. You know you're on the swim team. Yeah, I was on the swim team. I'd like to get back in the water. Maybe I'll go up to Cape Cod or something like that. I don't have a home up there, but I'll go up to Cape Cod or something like that. I don't have a home up there, but I would go up there, a main or something like that. Maybe somewhere like that, that would be nice.
我没法代替你。你知道你是游泳队的。对，我曾是游泳队的。我想重新回到水里。也许我会去科德角之类的地方。我在那没有房子，但我会去科德角之类的地方。我在那没有房子，但我会去那儿，缅因州或者之类的地方。也许去那样的地方，那会很不错。
Let me just say this, there are a lot of people, a lot of really bougie people who listen to our show. Give them your email if you've got a real nice play, if you've got a nice spread up there in the Cape or one of the island of vineyard or nantucket, and you'd like to have Paul Gianmatti as your house guest for a few days. Yeah, let us know on our Instagram.
让我直说吧，有很多人，很多非常讲究的人在听我们的节目。如果你有一个真正好的地方，如果你在科德角或马萨葡萄园岛或楠塔基特岛有一处好房产，并且你想让保罗·吉亚玛提（Paul Giamatti）做你几天的主客，就把你的电子邮件发给我们。是的，在我们的Instagram上让我们知道。
It's terrific. Somebody could host you. Let us know. And he's going to spend a lot of it. During the day, don't bother him. He's reading Lynn Dayton books, and he's going to be at the pool. What's that for dinner time?
太棒了。有人可以接待你。让我们知道。他会花很多时间在上面。白天不要打扰他。他在读林·代顿的书，他会在泳池边。晚餐时间吃什么？
Don't approach him if he's in the middle of the night. Nice class of Miss Gulley's not going to drink your wine, but give him a nice class. And then he'll discuss whatever you want. Awesome. Paul, you're well. Is that good well. We set up your summer for you. That's fantastic. Thank you. You're by the way, by the way,
如果他正忙着，就别去找他。格利小姐的好班级不会喝你的酒，但会给他倒一杯好酒。然后他会和你讨论你想讨论的任何事情。太棒了。保罗，你身体不错。这状态挺好吧。我们为你安排好了夏天。太棒了。谢谢。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，
all jokes you're gonna find, you're gonna find yourself on a fucking yacht in the Mediterranean because this is gonna be great. Oh, shit, that would be great. That's the demographic. That's the audience. That's the whole yacht. That's the first thing right now.
所有的笑话你都会发现，你会发现自己身处地中海的一艘豪华游艇上，因为这将会非常棒。哦，天哪，那太棒了。这就是目标受众。这就是观众。整艘游艇都是。这就是现在的第一件事。
It's all yacht. It's a real yachty crowd. Fantastic. Well, it is so nice to see you again. And to echo what Will said, I'm here in the city for quite a while. So maybe we could grab a bite. Let's do it. Let's do it. Make me happier than they have, then I've lunch with them. I'm going to get your contact info from our guys. If that's okay, pull them to reach out. Absolutely. It's a pleasure. Okay. And. Paul, I'm gonna reach out. Absolutely. Fantastic. Okay. And Jaygerson, when I'm out there sometime,
全是游艇。这群人真的很喜欢游艇。太棒了。很高兴再次见到你。呼应威尔的话，我要在城里待上一段时间。也许我们可以一起吃个便饭。那就这么定。那就这么定。这比他们让我高兴，然后我和他们一起吃午饭。我要从我们的人那儿拿到你的联系方式。如果可以的话，联系一下。当然。很高兴。好的。还有。保罗，我会联系的。当然。太棒了。好的。还有杰格森，当我什么时候去那儿的时候，
I'm gonna make a man. Yeah, you guys, you guys, face time, me from your lunch. Sure. Jay, we love you. We love you. But Paul can't wait. We love you, Jay.
我要创造一个男人。行啊，你们，你们吃午餐时跟我视频聊天吧。没问题。杰，我们爱你。我们爱你。但保罗等不及了。我们爱你，杰。
But Paul can't wait. It's gonna be a nice blessing. Bye, Clay. Thank you, Paul. You're my pleasure to meet you, my friend. Thank you. Yeah, real pleasure to meet you guys. Thank you very much.
但是保罗等不及了。这会是个美好的祝福。再见，克莱。谢谢你，保罗。很高兴认识你，我的朋友。谢谢。是的，很高兴认识你们。非常感谢。
Yeah, absolutely. My pleasure. See you down the road, by pal. Bye. Well, Will, you've, it was worth the wait. Right? No, I feel like I met him briefly. He's, I knew that he was friends with Thoreau, their old friends.
是的，绝对的。我的荣幸。再见，老朋友。再见。嗯，威尔，你，这等待是值得的。对吧？不，我觉得我简短地见过他。他，我知道他和梭罗是朋友，他们是老朋友。
And like I said, I've always just been such an admirer of his. Yeah, the credits are just endless. And that's what I meant, right? He's an actor's actor. Like we all as actors, where like, you know, if you were doing something to go, oh yeah, by the way, Jay Maddie's gonna do it. You'd be like, oh man, this thing is really
就像我说的，我一直非常崇拜他。是的，他的作品履历数不胜数。这就是我的意思，对吧？他是演员心中的演员。就像我们所有演员一样，你知道，如果你在做什么事情然后听到，哦，对了，顺便说一句，杰·马迪也要出演。你就会觉得，天哪，这东西真的很厉害
like, we have to like, we got totally. And I met him once at the Golden Globes years and years and years ago, but I didn't, you know, I didn't chat with him until right now. And talking to him at length now, you feel like he's one of those people like, oh, I feel like I know him forever. Like yeah.
就是，我们必须，我们完全是。我几年前在金球奖上见过他一次，但我当时没怎么跟他聊，直到现在。现在跟他长谈之后，你会觉得他是那种让你觉得“哦，我好像认识他一辈子了”的人。就像是这样的。
And he's the guy you would give any part to. Yeah. Yeah, he really does have that just, there's something about him when he inhabits a character. You're just with him. Yeah. Yeah. And he brings so much sort of pathos to every character. I
而且他就是那种你愿意把任何角色交给他的人。对。是的，他真的有那种特质，当他融入一个角色时，你就是会全心跟随他。对。是的。他给每个角色都注入了那么多的悲剧感和感染力。我
even enjoy watching his Verizon commercials. He's playing Einstein. I can't believe we didn't bring it up. I was going to. I was going to, but I was like, I guess I totally forgot. When he plays Santa Claus, right? Yeah. Because his service was playing Einstein. You stupid fox. Oh, I thought it was Santa Claus. Which would have brought it up and you would have said so when you play Santa and the Verizon career Listen, you know what though. I didn't know he was in Brooklyn. He lives so close to the ballast go Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts,
甚至喜欢看他的威瑞森广告。他扮演的是爱因斯坦。真不敢相信我们没提这事。我本来要说的。我本来要说的，但我当时想，我大概全忘了。当他扮演圣诞老人时，对吧？是的。因为他的服务商扮演的是爱因斯坦。你这头笨狐狸。哦，我还以为是圣诞老人。本来可以提起的，你也会这么说，所以当你扮演圣诞老人和威瑞森的职业生涯时……听着，不过你知道吗。我不知道他在布鲁克林。他住得离巴拉斯戈那么近。Smartless 是由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Unjurf 100% 有机且手工制作的。[♪ 片尾曲播放中 ♪] 我们的下一集将在共产主义一周后在您收听播客的任何地方发布，
or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app? When we think of sports stories, we tend to think of tales of epic on the field glory. But the new podcast, Sports Explains the World, brings you some of the wildest and most surprising sports stories you've never heard, like the teenager who wrote a fake Wikipedia page for a young athlete and then watched as a real team fell for his prank.
或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或Wondry应用中订阅Wondry Plus来提前收听无广告版？当我们想到体育故事时，我们往往会想到赛场上的史诗级辉煌。但全新的播客节目《体育解释世界》为你带来了你从未听过的最疯狂、最令人惊异的体育故事，比如那个少年为一个年轻运动员写了一个假的维基百科页面，然后眼睁睁地看着一支真正的球队上当受骗。
Diving into his Wikipedia page we turned three career goals into eleven, added twenty new assists for good measure. Figures that nobody would, should, have believed. And the mysterious secret of a US Olympic superstar killed at the peak of his career. Was it an accident? Did the police screw up the investigation? It was also nebulous.
翻阅他的维基百科页面，我们将三个职业目标变成了十一个，为了保险起见，还额外增加了二十次助攻。这些数据谁都不会、本该、也不可能相信。还有一个美国奥运超级巨星在职业生涯巅峰时期遇害的神秘事件。这是一场意外吗？警方把调查搞砸了吗？这也是极其模糊的。
Each week, Sports Explains the World goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports and their impact on the world. Listen to Sports Explains the World on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to sports explains the world early and ad-free on Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
每周，“体育解释世界”节目超越了联赛和数据本身的局限，分享那些将重新定义你对体育及其对世界影响的理解的故事。请在 Wondery 应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方收听“体育解释世界”。你可以在 Wondery Plus 上提前且无广告地收听“体育解释世界”。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。